e
I do enjoy doing that I don't know why
uh thank you for all tning up tonight to
tonight's planning committee b um my
name is Andy Crum will be chairing
tonight's meeting in line with normal
processes and here to discuss the
planning merits of the applications
before us uh I'd like to have some
housekeeping first um we're not
expecting a firearm so if you do hear
one uh as corpal Jones would say don't
panic and follow the officers
out secondly can iure people have
switched their phones are to silent or
off because there's nothing worse than a
speaker being interrupted by sounds of
the great skape or sex bom other song
you've got on your phone can the kettle
the hunting tune I believe you got on
yours so if you could make sure that
one's up as well good mam thank you um
and also can you bear with me please
that people who have reged to speak are
the only ones who are allowed to speak
and please do not interrupt speakers it
might be very very tempting I might be
able to sympathize with you on the
occasions but you are not allowed to
interrupt unless you are reged to speak
um in
people won't stop interrupting I have
the option to clear the uh the gallery
and the day I've had today that could be
an option so please please bear with me
I'm not normally as grumpy my name's
Andy Grump not Andy Grump but please
bear with me thank you right um can we
move on to item on the agenda which is
apologies for absence no apologies chair
thank you disclosures of Interest item
number two CC the Fielding
disclose that I'm member for
number
19312 you counc
Kettle um two points Mr chairman one as
chairman of the council I did rece
commun
about item four on the
agenda um from the land owner he wrote
he contact me as chairman of the council
which I then passed on to Mr Grafton uh
for him to um consider the second thing
um as members will be aware um owing to
an accident I had six weeks ago sitting
for a long period of time can be a bit
of a challenge so with the Chairman's
permission I will be I all need to stand
up and walk around I haven't lost got
away with the fairies well no more than
usual uh but it's just to um I need if I
stay here all night I'll get stuck and I
won't move hopefully it's temporary
thank you can schedle as another fellow
artificial hip person I fully sympathize
with you and as long as you're paying
attention I've got no issues with
that
uh yes I would also declare that
uh for the first application item number
48329 F at napton I will be stepping out
I step the previous application am known
to the applicant so C the Mills will be
presenting that
item right thank you um
minutes yes Intrust the people at the
top here you know I'm rabbiting on who I
am and who the members are but the most
important people here are the opposite
and I'll start on my right with Olivia
oliv
Services Ross Chambers Legal
Services good evening my name is Dale
Barker I'm the planning manager for
tonight's meeting my role is to provide
impartial advice to clarify any planning
issues that arise and to assist members
decision taking I'm Bound by the
worldtown planning institute's code of
professional conduct planning committee
members are not bound by advice from
officers or by their
Alice Co senior
planner Sarah mcon
planner brotherstone planner Jose Brook
planner Matt coin senior
planner thank you very much must sound
like Jeremy Paxman here yeah
and I'm sure I'm sure they are a lot
wiser right so going on to item three
which is the minutes um I assum people
read those and happy that I can sign
those at true record as the meeting held
on the 21st of
August thank you I'll those later and
we'll move on to the next item on the
agenda which catch the Mills will be
chairing thank
you
good evening ladies and gentlemen thank
you I'll be chairing the first item on
the agenda and then of course Council
Crum will follow on the other items on
the agenda
um on this particular item which is
application 18 oblique 03 239 of League
F uh field between dog lane Fels lanp
um we won't be here to debate uh the
whole application tonight um but this is
to consider whether to make an
amendments to the published reasons for
granting the P
application um so the options open to
the uh committee are the committee could
endorse an amend and an amendment to the
reasons for Grant contained in the
minute set out in set out in paragraph
1.9 of the above
the committee could make an alternative
amendments to the
minutes the committee could decide not
to make any Amendment to the
minutes the committee could decide to
reconsider the application at a
subsequent meeting of the planning
committee and determine whether or not
to Res send their previous resolution to
Grant thank you and I believe uh Mr
Buckland you're going to make
presentation over to you very briefly
now chairman because you you've covered
most of the points um you're not going
to talk I will talk just for a short
time um so so just by a further
background following the consideration
of the application um minute 875
captured the decision to ground and
identified two reasons for
ground the monitor officer after being
prompted by an NA on the hill Parish
Council considered the complaint in
relation to that particular minute and
the decision and as is laid out in
paragraph 1.7 of the report the monitor
of was satisfied that the minutes of the
Mee insufficiently clear and do not
adequately explain the committee's
resolution for granting the planning
permission we as officers have reviewed
the meeting and the webcast and the
transcript of the meeting you'll have
attached to your committee report
tonight at transcript from that
particular
meeting we believe that we could
recommend an amendment to the minutes to
fully capture reasons for grant that
were discussed in the meeting but were
not captured with the appr minute they
are laid out at paragraph
1.9 as you've discussed chairman your
options tonight are that you consider
amending the minutes for that meeting
minute 875 to reflect the the um two
bullet points identified at
1.9 if you are unhappy to change the
minutes for that particular meeting the
option that I would then be forced with
is that given the risk of legal
challenge we wouldn't be able to Grant
the application would seek to have a
reconsideration of that application by
this committee so your your options
chairman are to either consider an
amendment or refuse the
amendment thank you Mr buland uh Council
fing I'm happy to
endorse
the application for us
and set out by our
Lear
so was that um sorry sorry
Peter yeah I'm behind
here um right um right we can vote on
this now um Ross are you you want
to so it's been proposed and seconded
do I
have a proposal do I accept this
recommendation or
not been proposed yes do we have a vote
on this
now can we vote for it yes you
happy yeah so Council Fielding has
proposed amending the
in line with paragraph 1.9 of the report
that's been seconded by councilor bars
so all those in
favor in faor sorry all those in
favor those
against any
extensions
no so committee's resolved to amend the
minutes in accordance with the report
okay
thank you Mr buckin you can
go
right thank you very much Council Ms for
handing that one for me
uh right yeah um right we're asking for
a change of order now a brief change of
order um I would like to bring
application number nine which is 19
01513 F land adjacent to White cotage
Church Street
wellsborne uh as the next item of
business uh the reason for doing this is
because it was brought to this committee
due to an objection by the parish
council the parish council is not able
to
attend and neither is the ward
member our usual rules uh state that if
that happens we seek to dedicate
approval to
officers there's a slight Amendment
slight change slightly different on this
one because the parish council have
actually written in saying they couldn't
attend but here's their here's their
objection
um and you I am minded that we delegate
this to officers because it's set a
president we want people we want prish
councilors to attend so we can speak to
them in person and tease out the details
that are not in their written
submissions however they have sent
something in so that's what I'm minded
to do but I will be seeking guidance
from yourselves whether to actually hear
the a which is a couple of written
statements or to delegate to
offices so Council
fing um I'm happy that we delegated to
the officers because if people don't
turn up we can't question them we also
find out a lot of points from the
questioning and therefore I'm quite
happy to accept your
ruling this was what I was minded to I'm
seeking guidance from yourself
my guid I'm happy okay counc
bars as the joining Ward member and the
parish council meeting last night at
lington which is next to the site
they're quite happy I do feel it's not
good when people can't turn up and I
would go along with um leaving it to the
offices but the adjoining Ward member
and Parish Council are happy with the
recommendation CC
J we are talking here about the land
south of a46 have I got that correctly
no sorry my my hearing I didn't quite go
yes um item number nine lond adjacent to
white cottage Church Street wellsborne
okay that's fine thank
you
um I take a slightly different view to
my colleagues um the parish council
Parish Council has written in I would be
as there's nothing on the update shoot
about that letter I'm not sure whether
it's been included in the officer's
report um and therefore whether it be
possible for that letter to be read
before we take the we'll go for the vote
then we'll go to vote obviously we've
had a proposal and the second to
delegate it to officers and we'll go to
the vote obviously you've got contrary
opinion so um I'm happy to go to the
vote can before point out I think
Council bars has got the wrong um s
refering Ward member I didn't need a w
member neighboring world he might be
neighboring
yes right let's right we'll start again
then just to make sure where we're clear
can we just have a bit quiet please s
right just to make it sure because K the
bar seconded The Proposal from ker the
fiing we need to make sure we are
looking at the right application which
is the
one item number nine land adjacent
Cottage Church Street
wellsborne page page 107 and the reason
it's here for committee's uh discussion
is that the parish council have objected
the parish council haven't turned up but
have written in saying why they couldn't
turn up and could their objection still
be heard the ward member has written in
saying she can't attend due to
longstanding engagement and she is um
you know she wants her statement R out
as
well my reason for bringing it
Forward is to I'm concerned we're
setting a president because we want
people to turn up and speak at
committee
yeah
so we've had a proposal from C the
Fielding who was Happ who agrees with my
my opinion it's not my recommendation my
opinion my
that we should delegate this to officers
but we haven't got a second because I
think C the bars was
seconding something
differently so I'm looking for is there
anybody willing canel the kettle I'll go
back to what I said I think there has
been a letter written in which is not
included in the update sheet um and
therefore we should at
least we go to that I so we don't
prolong us any further I will second
Council the field prop proposal that we
delegate this to officers so all those
in favor of delegating this one to
officers please vote
now seven chairman
against one chairman so committee
recommends that application
19513 F land adjacent to White cage
Church Street W is dedicated for
officers approval due to the the reasons
we mentioned thank you right good glad
you're getting there two down
now our next application is
19142 out L south of the a46 west of the
proposed Western relief Road aler Road
struct on Raven and it's a hybrid pent
application detailing all the items in
the agenda so we present Alice on to
that one
please thank you chairman the
application as identified the black dot
in the center of the plan is located to
the western side of Stratford within its
built up Pera
boundary the application site is
allocated for Employment Development and
a proposal sua2 this slide shows the
core strategy inset map which identifies
the location of the sua2 allocation as
well as the built up area boundary of
Stratford denoted by the thick black
outline the approved west of shy relief
Road when constructed would align the
eastern boundary of the
the application site which lies to the
south of the a46 is outlined in red on
the plan the purple area is also
allocated under proposal sua2 but for
residential development this element of
the allocation has been granted planning
permission and is occupied the
application before members this evening
is a hybrid planning application which
seeks outline consent with matters of
appearance Landscaping layout and scale
reserved for the development of a mixed
Ed Business Park uses include offices
research and development and Industrial
uses storage and distribution car
showrooms buky Goods retail store and a
cafe immunity facility full planning
permission is sought for a new
roundabout access from the a46 internal
spine Road leveling and structural
Landscaping the application is a
resubmission of a previous scheme which
was refused on the basis of insufficient
information to demonstrate that the
highways impacts would be acceptable and
the lack of a signed legre secure the
relevant contributions and
obligations the colored areas on this
plan shows the parts of the site where
full planning permission is sought the
new access roundabout from the a46 can
be seen along with the associated
realignment of the Dron Mana drive
internal access road and structural
Landscaping which is denoted by the dark
green areas on the plan the structural
Landscaping includes native structure
planting to the South and West
boundaries of the site and new tree and
Native H planting along the internal
Access
Road in relation to the HED R along the
a46 the majority of the Hedge would be
retained but would be managed as a laid
HED R approximately 0.9 meters in height
a section close to the new axis
roundabout would be replaced with new
hedge R planting the high press water M
which currently crosses the site would
be diverted along its eastern boundary
the light green shading along this
boundary denotes Meadow planting where
the water man prevents the planting of
trees in respect of outline element of
the scheme the parameters plan
identifies various development zones
which are proposed both development
zones 1 a and 1B which front onto the
a46 propos buildings up to a height of
12 MERS whilst both development zones
two and three toward the south of the
site proposed buildings up to a height
of 18 M meters at its closest the
residential development to the east of
the site which will lie beyond the west
of shter relief road is located in
excess of 85 meters from the closest
development Zone
an illustrative master plan has been
submitted which shows car showrooms and
a bulky Goods retail store along the a46
frontage office and Industrial units are
shown within the southern half of the
site members should note that as the
development zones are proposed in
outline at this stage this plan has been
submitted for illustrative purposes
only this photo is taken stood on the
Northern side of the a46 with the
application site beyond the Hedge R and
W more roundabout behind
us is taken looking the other way so
where Dron Mana Drive meets the
a46 this is the approximate location for
the new site access round about this
photo is taken looking at dayon Mana
Drive in a Northerly Direction the
residential development of Midsummer
Park which lies to the eastern boundary
of the site can just about be seen in
the distance over here chairman the
recommendation is to Grant the
application in accordance with the
recommendation detailed in the committee
agenda thank you chairman
and have our first Speaker which is
counselor Toby Lee from stford paven
Town
Council good evening
councel good evening you've got three
minutes would you like a warning Shout
with about 30 seconds to go yeah that's
great right far away when you're ready
please okay
so we first discussed this application
in June at the Town Council
and our decision then was to object to
the
proposal um in principle we've got no
issue with the concept of the
development it's very clearly within the
development plan the core strategy for
the district council and also within the
neighborhood development plan which has
been approved by the the good citizens
of ston a um the issue primarily we have
with this development is the access so
we provided three reasons as to why we
objected to it back in June these are
that it doesn't conform to the policy
set out in the um core strategy which
envisages access either coming from the
existing
roundabout or from the proposed South
well proposed and consented Southwest
relief
Road um the second reason is down to
potential Prejudice of inserting a new
island onto a road which is known but
not proposed to be extended as as a dual
courage way and third reason we gave was
really detail around the access from a
pedestrian and cyclist point of view for
what will be quite a a large
developmental obiously would like to
encourage people to be able to access a
site other than cars to be fair to
who also here today they have engaged
with us so we're very appreciative of
that so we had a meeting with them and
we have actually debated this again and
we debated it last night um and again
again thanks for the Developers for
attending the meeting and addressing the
to
council we have however kept to the same
position um it is that we do not believe
it's appropriate to have a a second
roundabout when the core strategy is
clearly
sets out the two means of
access we do believe that access from
the southwestern road is not viable and
I think the developer has proven that it
will limit the development of the site
but we see no reason why a larger
roundabout incorporating fire Spurs can
be developed to enable this development
as you as you you will all be aware
travel further at the a46 you do cons
roundabout
um so I think that probably probably
sums up what I'd like to say thank you
very much thank you very much time any
questions to councelor Lee
please counc c um might be one of the
officers but can you tell me the the
distance from the two roundabouts the
existing roundabout and the proposed
roundabout might be better for the um
officer to give the like add
supplementary to that question cycle
access how would you envisage a cycle
access what would be the your preferred
cycle access
R well it's really down to the lack of
detail which is there which we have the
issue with um The Proposal includes a
cycle route which follows the existing
roundabout so what we've been able to
not been able to determine as a Town
Council is what the access will look
like in practice though I'm aware that
there will be certainly conditions from
highways England for the developer to
study that um for us it's just the lack
of clarity on that and what we believe
is important that people have both
pedestrian and well safe pedestrian and
cycle access to the
site thank you and good evening
so your recommend what you would like
would it be a cycle Lane in in here
because that that 846 is pretty
busy yes I mean it's coming up with the
right solution and obviously what we've
been presented within this application
is a solution which sits within an
existing roundabout which we know will
be altered for the southern um
Southwestern relief road we would like
to see safe Crossing for pedestrians and
for
cyclists
right thank
you yeah I've got a couple questions
counc um first the comments please and
that the developers actually engageing
with yourselves um so that's that's
quite
laudable
um so your first your major complaint is
about the roundabout um and the access
and the second one is the there's a
commitment to a potential dueling of the
the 46 and you're saying that by
allowing this you potentially feel that
wouldn't happen or it could hinder that
taken
place yeah I mean I wouldn't say it
wouldn't happen but it it is potentially
making it more difficult yeah um we do
appreciate the developer has actually
set back the development and has
specifically ensure there is space at
the northern edge of the development to
allow
so I think that's a a good move by the
developer but again the principle is
you've got two roundabouts relatively
close together and we feel that a a
large roundabout would would be better
suited and be in alignment with the plan
as set out in the core
strategy and the other bit The
Pedestrian and cycl axis obviously you
know District Cel declared a climate
emergency a few weeks ago uh and we're
trying to encourage people to have
sustain
with prot access and cycle
access you're basically saying that you
support the principle of it but what so
what it is all the details you've been
presented with are not suitable or you
think they could be improved what's
what's your opinion there yeah I mean
obviously if you look at the the picture
on the screen you can sort of see where
the proposal is for a cycle route which
follows the existing roundabout and in
the background you can then see then
going over um the proposed roundabout
for the southwestern relief road we
would like much more clarity what that
access will look like yeah that's that's
great I just wanted to make sure make
sure we're clarified where but thought
on but that's very clear thank you very
much no further questions thank you C
you're free to
go our next speaker is leis Payne please
and I believe you're being supported by
coup of gentlemen as
well you could uh introduce yourself
please okay thank you Mr chairman three
minutes good evening ladies and
gentlemen uh thank you very much for
allowing us to address you this evening
my name is leis Payne I'm development
director at IR properties and as you say
I've got Daman holdstock from Turley who
is our planning representative and James
B from my transport who is our transport
expert on this
one properties are one of the largest
privately owned property companies in
the UK and we've got a long experience
of delivering sustainable developments
of business Parks particularly in the
West Midlands region so uh Parks like BL
Valley Park in Sol Hall and four
business park and Birch Copus in North
warshire we're the Freehold owners of
this site we've owned it since 2016
and in that time we've been committed to
delivering a vision of a a high quality
sustainable Business Park in this
location we're looking to create
longlasting economic benefits for the
district uh construction jobs during the
building of the scheme up to
1,650 jobs once the scheme's completed
and crucially up to 2.8 million pounds
worth of business rate Revenue uh that
will be generated for the district once
the scheme is complete we're also
looking to create wider benefits uh for
the district creating a good place to
work that not only attracts new
businesses into the district but also
provides space for existing strapford
upon aen businesses to grow and
Thrive the application before you is a a
culmination of three years of hard work
um in order to prepare a planning
application that we believe is robust
sustainable and crucially deliverable um
and the planning application consistent
with the objectives set out in the core
strategy we've been careful to ensure
that the any impacts of our proposals
are mitigated and this has included
regular and extensive discussions with
both highways England who control the
a46 and warer County Council highways
and this has led us to agreeing an
extensive package of offsite highways
mitigation which total around about 3.4
million pounds to be spent across Bley
Crossroads wild roundabout and also
bishop and
roundabout um as has already been
discussed briefly we're looking at
making improvements to cycling of
pedestrian connectivity to the site and
we're also making public con uh public
transport contributions for improved bus
services to the site which we believe is
is crucial in making this a sustainable
place for people to work and a connected
Place 30 seconds okay our proposal is
include significant landscape Works
including the planting of over 1,700 new
trees and over a th000 meters of new
hedro and finally importantly we believe
that our proposals are consistent with
the core strategy supporting economic
growth providing an opportunity for
straid upon aen businesses to grow and
providing the potential for the delivery
of new homes and regeneration in the
canal quarter so we respectfully request
that you support our Pro proposals
tonight thanks for your time and please
feel free to ask any questions thank you
Mr P Spot on any questions
C the field in then C the bars then C
Unit
um are you putting in any starting units
in there for new businesses and others
that can for incat type set
up um there's potential to do that sir
yes um at the moment uh the details
around the buildings that are going to
go onto the site are in outline only um
we are just about to commence uh a
marketing um Str
uh for the site which has actually been
submitted to uh the council um and what
we've tried to do is give ourselves
flexibility to respond to Market uh
demands but potentially starter units
could could form an element of that I
think the difficulty that we've got is
Mr P I think you you've answer that
thank
you I know you in full FL but I
think catch the catch the
bars the question I was going to ask was
mentioned at light
pollution places as you obviously know
where it is um it may be an opposite
question but I think there is concern
locally about light
pollution I asked a question on
technically so just to confirm in
respect of light pollution that is
something which has considered through
the planning application um a detailed
report looking at the potential um like
pollution from the site has been
submitted and assessed by the council's
environmental health officer um there
there there are no um issues or concerns
in respect of light
pollution really when it comes to the
detailed design stage there will be a
requirement to ensure that all light
fittings are um sort of designed in a
way that minimizes light spill and
actually it's been designed designed to
to to Really look at the sensitive
receptors in respect of ecological um
areas but also the nearest neighboring
residents as
well
J uh you've mentioned sustainability now
whilst I appreciate this is an outline
and that um uh details are reserved for
detail later on um this Council does
have a duty for mitigation and
adaptation for climate change um and you
all know all the section 19 planning and
compulsory act 2004 and um 2008 planning
act and then the climate change 2008 uh
and the meron rule which has not yet
been um um never been repealed so what
other mitigation and adaptation would
you be intending to on this site would
you would renewable energy be something
you will be considering obviously this
is outline and and that might be for
detail but um just want to have some
assurance that um that sustainability
will mean actual sustainability uh
including renewable energy and I also
note that um there may be an issue with
biodiversity offset uh and then I also
have the um the concern as well over the
U um this what is actually on the table
today which is the um um the road uh and
um the um the the the impact of um the
highways okay just on sustainability I
think you're absolutely right you know
this is uh the detail of the buildings
are in outline so it's difficult to be
too specific at this point what I would
say is that as a company um we're very
um tuned into uh trying to create
developments that are as sustainable as
possible um so you know as a standard
across um our Logistics and Office
Buildings for example we we use things
like LED uh lighting um uh and we really
concentrate on the fabric of the
building to make them as energy
efficient as possible so we we always
try to maximize energy performance
certificate uh ratings on our building
for example at BL Valley some of the
recent offices that we've built have
been have been a rated buildings um I
think looking at the other point about
sustainability and trying to min car
travel and things like that uh you know
all our buildings have uh cycle storage
uh and then we also look as standard at
putting things like shower facilities
and stuff like that in our buildings to
try and encourage different modes of
Transport umiversity do you want to pick
that one up yeah so on biodiversity um
we have had discussions with warshire
County Council uh there is a requirement
for biodiversity offsetting that's those
conversations are ongoing but there will
be 106 requirements to uh secure a
scheme of biodiversity offsetting uh on
this site and we're looking at various
different options for uh for for
ensuring that there's no net loss in in
terms of
biodiversity was it almost 900,000
section 106 was that mentioned in the
report there was one other item which
again it is not at this stage but just
just to to make you aware that um we we
are very conscious of the need for
renewable energy on sites as well if if
um if
appro counc
CLE two points one if I just follow
councelor Jet's points up um firstly in
respect of lighting we know LED lighting
is far more efficient and effective than
historic lighting it is also stunningly
unattractive and whilst we're told
repeatedly no lighting Halo um that is
always in dry conditions if however the
tarmac or whatever surface is wet then
the impact of the very bright LED
lighting is to create um as much Halo if
not greater halo effect uh than any
other lighting schemes currently
available in the market I believe
particularly since the climate change um
motion was passed at last Mee that we
shouldn't be just aiming at meeting set
we should be looking for the best
possible standard and merely tying into
where we are isn't really acceptable in
any longer so putting in very very
bright LED lights yes it may be energy
efficient but in terms of overp from
that it can be considerably worse yeah
um Ross was thinking exactly the same is
there a question I think there's sort of
a
question the question what can you do to
that you'll be doing for the best
possible option rather than I think um
just to clarify on the point that I made
about LED lighting I I was talking about
the uh internal lighting of buildings as
well as external I think that whatever
lighting we choose for the exterior
areas of the park we need to be in
accordance with the the lighting
assessment that we've put to the council
in terms of Lux levels and and know
light spill and things along those lines
you know from an ecology perspective so
whatever specification of Lights we
chose we would be looking to do so in
accordance with the information that
we've submitted to The District Council
on
that my my next Point Mr as long as
you're briefly on this one question
please um policy sua 2 which is in front
of me here says vehicle access to
Employment Development directly off
windmore roundabout of proposed western
western relief Road um you said that
this comp with the strategy but in my
understanding um having just read what
it says um you're not you're not in
compy core strategy because cor strategy
says one thing and you're doing
something fundamentally different which
I think was raised early on has an
impact on the possible duning of the
a46 um therefore I've got a problem why
why can't you take a roundabout straight
up C Kettle I don't think the dueling of
the 846 is in the core strategy is it
no but the comment here is that it will
be coming off to well well more well
well more roundabout and they're saying
something completely different yeah I
accept that but I think the a46 probably
isn't relevant as part of the
question I'm glad you asked me that
question I was going to sit here
silently
um we've been working on access
arrangements for this site for more than
the last three years we engaged with
highways England back in um 2015 in
terms of the access arrangements to the
site if you look at the plan up on the
screen um the two options which are
envisaged by the policy are either
access from the relief Road or enlarging
the um wild more roundabout to provide a
fifth arm to serve the site in terms of
the former there simply isn't enough
Frontage to provide a suitable access to
serve the site um you might be able to
serve one building from such an access
but you certainly wouldn't be able to
deliver development envisaged by the
local plan and the reason for that is
there's just not enough space between
the world more roundabout and whatever
form of access you provide from relief
Road for stacking space for safety for
you know vehicles coming off one
Junction and joining another in terms of
a fifth arm off the
roundabout the problem with wildemore is
that the three arms are all to the south
of the junction and trying to squeeze a
fourth arm on results in technical terms
a whacking great round round and it
would be enormous um and the trouble
with large roundabouts putting to one
side land ownership issues is you get
very high circulatory speeds if you ever
tried to join a junction a roundabout
which is UN signalized very large people
come around it really fast it's
difficult to join and they don't
actually work very well in in terms of
capacity you'd inevitably have to
signalize such a junction and you'd
actually have a much worse operation in
terms of delay trying to get along the
than what we've proposed which is two
Junctions they're roundabouts they are
they will be free flowing and they work
exceptionally well so you're better off
with this Arrangement than you are with
what's envisaged in the adopted um plan
and I know that the emerging plan um
there is an amendment to the policy
which does suggest that access can be
from the
a46 I hope that helps yes thank you any
other questions I've got about one in a
bit um I touched on um I was going back
the 10 council's objections we've
touched on the roundabout the first one
the second one was the jeweling which is
a potential
commitment um but not agreed yet so
again if you just give us your comments
on that and the other bit again we've
touched on it um C CLE and cancer J
about The Pedestrian and cycle access
and I believe you've been in
conversation with the Town Council and
they I think they want some more detail
so just question about that
b so dealing with the dueling first
um there is no proposal for dueling it's
there is no um plan for it there are
aspirations which have been discussed
but nothing more than that um so if a
harsh view were being taken we would
just simply ignore it um what we what we
have done is allowed for future jeweling
by safeguarding the land along the
northern boundary of the site but in
terms of the Des of the junction the
site access Junction yes it would need
to be redesigned with dueling um to a
certain extent it would probably be
relatively minor because the junction
has two lane approaches on both a46 arms
so it's actually fairly minor works but
I think if highways England do comes to
you the a46 that site access roundabout
will be the least of their problems
thinking about all the other various
Junctions up and down the a46 that will
be a relatively easy win um pedestrian
cyclist access um we have prep two
options um to get a good level of
pedestrian cyclist access into the site
that option there on the screen is the
without relief Road and so that shows a
3 meter footway Cycle Way connecting
around the southern side of the wild
round about and connecting with the
existing provision on oler road to the
east of the roundabout uh and we've also
prepared an arrangement which um is
similar to that but obviously crosses
the relief Road um in the forearm wild
uh function arrangement with the relief
Road um both options have been subject
to the scrutiny of warshire Highways
England highways England's plethora of
consultants and it's one of the things
that they aren't fully satisfied
with thank you very much I do like the
word Leora Leora that's that's a great
word I I do like that word I must have
it right um gentlemen I don't think
there's any further questions you're
free to go thank
you right we'll move on to points of
clarification to the officers any points
of clarification cancor junid then
cancor Mills just beting there Chris
sorry I I would like to have some more
information about the the road and the
access because um well as you know I I
live in oler I use that road a
lot the other day and and it's very
common that you can't get onto that road
at all there long long cues of traffic
right way back to the um the other
roundabout which is the roundabout on
the other side of of of Stratford as it
was the other night
so I I'm not
satisfied so far with what I've heard
about the plans for making sure that
there is free flow of traffic along that
road particularly around 5:00 so perhaps
officers could clarify a little bit with
me why they've considered that they are
happy with
um with that that access on that
road please you chair um there has been
as as mentioned by the applicants a
great deal of both PR discussion with
highways England and County highways and
subsequent discussions throughout the
course of the previous application and
this Mission and one of the matters was
whether the access on the a46 was
acceptable so um for the reasons
outlined by the applicant there they
were basically put to highways England
and highways confirmed in their
consultation response that they're
satisfied with the principle of access
in that location there's no reason to
their mind why they can justify
recommending refusal or objection on the
basis of of that site access um the
other things I would just like to pick
up on just following um comments made by
the speakers is um yes the core strategy
uh proposes access from Mar round about
the west of sha road but the proposed
submission site allocation plan does
account the possibility in access
directly from the a46 the reason being
that we now have more information um
from both highways andon County highways
to confirm that it's not possible to
gain access from a while rounds about
the Wester shter road for the reasons
provided and the other thing I'd just
like to pick up on is the uh statford
neighborhood development plan which was
um adopted as you know after the core
strategy and therefore should be given
essentially more weight um one of the
points in the NDP polic which relates
specifically application sites with
policy
ssb2 um states that development was
supported for a number of reasons uh or
subject to following requirements one
such requirement is safe access and
erress from the wild roundabout Western
relief Road or other suitable location
supported by the highway Authority so to
my mind that there's not a policy
conflict or at least if we do give more
weight or equal weight to the court
strategy and say that the rzes is
currently worded we've obviously got the
no objection from high to show that
there isn't an unacceptable highways
impact as a result of that
access you councel
NS actually Mr chairman I'm along the
same lines as Council junion just a bit
concerned about the access but this but
um as was saying are you saying that
their neighborhood
plan accepts this or has it been adopted
in the neighborhood plan yes so like I
said the adopted policy um so
development on this be supported if it
could be demonstrated following
requirements are met and there's six
requirements laid out one of which is
safe access and egress while rounds
about Western relief Road or other
suitable locations supported by the
highway Authority so as you know the
recommendation is subject to highways
Inland removing their objection their
objection relates to the off-site
highway mitigation scheme not the site
access on the a46 so to my mind that
part of the policy and NDP policy is met
thank Youk CLE
um if I read page 42
correctly um highways England
recommended that planning permission not
be granted for a specific period
brackets three months that's quite clear
highways England is not yet comfortable
with the
proposal um and yet you're saying to us
that highways England are in support
person um could you resolve that
conflict the update sheet you read the
update sheet yeah just to clarify I'm
not saying that highways England is
supported the proposal I'm I'm saying
that they've raise no objection to the
site access onto the a46 so the
outstanding matters which highways
England are not satisfied that they can
raise their objection on are summarized
in the update sheet but in principle
they've accepted the offsite highways
mitigation schemes the question now
relates to departures from standards
which have to go through certain teams
with Highway
and also the trigger points for when
those offsite mitigation schemes come
in so to follow upon
that if we were minded to approve we
could put a condition in that approval U
The Works would only take place once the
highrise England mutters have been
resolved essentially as the
recommendation is worded it's subject to
Hing and lifting their objection be able
even if members were minded to approve
tonight I wouldn't be able to determine
the application until that highways
England objection is raised um as set
out in the summary of recommendations so
there wouldn't need to be any sort of
condition to that effect there's already
recommended conditions which require the
implementation of the offsite highways
mitigation schemes um but that's that's
sort of the situation as it
stands yes yes
yes um as already indicated and though
this is outlined and it's not for now it
it is my
um I will be
requiring uh if any for any further you
know detailed stage so it's just making
sure that uh it is noted that we will
require climate change mitigation and
adaptation as as I outlin to the
applicants included in minutes so it's
we've got a record of that so thank you
that CC J fil then back to CC k um I
think it's a tragedy that it's not being
taken to Du carriageway because it is a
bottleneck all the way along that road
but be that as it may it's it's down to
highways
England um so I can't but I think it
would be also important if we can insist
or maybe we can't U to have starter
units there because I know in straford
um in shipston when I was canvasing
major complaints with all those houses
being built there was nowhere for
businesses to be set up um and
unless people can be dealt with then
it's a problem I think Alice has got a
question to answer there I think
she's a question from
that so Council building the allocation
isn't does incorporate any sort of
proposals to stter units the allocation
doesn't include any proposal of starter
unit but of course you you've heard what
the applicant said in terms of that is
something they will consider as as the
site comes forward the thing I would
just like to highlight is part of the
the site is to enable Canal quarter
relocation units to come here to allow
the bringing bard of the canal quter
which is allocated under sua one in the
court strategy so we're we're already
getting that and there'll also be a
limit um a minimum on the number of
offices which we have on the site so we
are ensuring that we are me polic sua um
beyond that if we're going into starting
units I think it's something which we
can obviously request from the applicant
but perhaps not something which we can
insist on chairman I must apologize I
left my hearing a behind yeah no
problem I'm being told by Dale that
there are starter units in D and Manor
Farm which is just down this area
here I can't
confir right C Kettle um
the section 106 on this application will
will be drawn off on the back of this
application that this outline
application not on the reserve M
application so therefore if we want to
get any conditions in um it needs to be
done at this stage and if it isn't done
this stage it's too late and therefore I
think we should consider very carefully
and ensure um that we don't miss the bus
with so with with any requirements we
might need to come in um so that was
just a a point I confirm that with
officers that's correct if they outline
matters they should be controlled at
this stage where Reserve matters can you
just clarify what you're alluding
to what it's really bringing up um I
mean Council Juno was talking about
renewable energy which I think is
fundamental to where we are now as a
local Authority with our climate change
um view um I think also in terms of
lighting we need to ensure that um every
effort is made not to meet the minimum
standard but to meet the maximum
possible available on the market and I'm
not quite sure how we' word that um but
we've seen in my ward the appalling
impact of LED lighting um which on a wet
and foggy night lights up the whole of
South warshire we need to avoid that now
we've learned our mistakes therefore
section 106 is the time to get that
right so I think we need before
considering this application we need to
consider very carefully what conditions
we as a committee should seek to includ
in that in addition to what we've
already got again if we got a question
Kettle we can try and stick to more
concise questions I know we've got to
have some contextual background but can
we try and get to the questions a more
quickly sorry Alice I was just going to
pick up a couple of things I take from
that um firstly I think it' be more
appropriate to condition something like
that rather than have it in a 106 if
we're requiring certain sustainability
credentials um I covered energy
conservation in my report and obviously
um the the detail design being where we
will understand what if any renewable
sources are proposed I'm conscious that
our policy CS2 only encourages uh the
provision of low and zero carbon
Technologies so I would be nervous about
putting a condition on the outline to
require a scheme for lower renewable
sources to come forward with the reserve
matters but having said that if members
interpret policies differently and and
wish to determine the application with
that addition
then obviously officers Will Follow That
recommend that
resolution right any again I think that
um the um not withstanding what is in
the course strategy I actually do think
we've got
national uh support for the for the
requirements for mitigation and
adaptation and
um under the the merchant rule the
renewable energy um requirements are
there so I would like more information
from the officers as to what is possible
so you're asking for more information
from the officers on how we can
condition a improved or Innovative or
more effective form of energy
use I think Mr generation as well as use
it's all very well having an insulated
building if using fossil Fu happy to
accept that Amendment yeah as long as we
become up the conditions that are
reasonable appropriate
R necessary and so we've got to make
sure the conditions are not unreasonable
so again just to that into account catch
the bars yes it was just something that
the Africans said
about6 agreement
in the improving the
crossroads towards the
Stag um would like that done obviously
many years ago we did want an island
because there are rare bats there you
can't have lights but I think they
mentioned it they would support that
Crossing I think it would be appropriate
to put that in this outlaw permission if
the committee
agree
um if counc you're referring to build
Crossroads that is one of the schemes
that offsite instigation schemes which
proposed so the three which we're
referring to are builds of Crossroads
wild and bishopton and there' been
schemes drawn up by the applicant and
that's bsy Crossroad so this one here so
are you talking further down the
a46 yeah that's the one can you see on
on the plan number one that's talking
about no there's not there's not a
proposal
lights an improvement scheme that both
count county has acely said it will
improve safety at that
location
right just one thing on under the update
sheet uh we're talking about a 10year
period for submission Reserve matters um
as opposed to three why such a ex this
is a very experienced developer they've
already talked about their
development
value um why um why we giving him such a
long
period the reasons are provided in the
update sheet so given the scale of
development it is anticipated it would
come forward on a phased basis we're
talking about 25 hectares of development
here so it's reasonable that it's going
to take some time to get potential
occupiers um interested to design sches
to subse in um so it's quite normal for
a scheme of this size to have a longer
time period I discussed this with
planning policy earlier and policy
proposal su2 expects delivery within the
plan period so up to 2031 so it seems
reasonable that the submission Reserve
matters and sub build out follows that I
think was
mention right should we G for the debate
who wants to start cat the bars thank
you well I don't see any problem may or
may not be in the core
strategy we need the employment s
whatever Road it's on it's full of
traffic
anyway um highways to a certain
extent are happy with it so I can't
judge their
judgment there is improvements of the
road liting concern of the locals which
will which will be address hopefully at
the detail stage so I'm happy
to yes thanks Mr chairman
um
yeah this um this extra roundabout I
think prob be a must there we can't OB
wild it does sound like a super scheme
to me and say the employment bring in
and revenue for the
counil um so yes I'm quite happy with
the right I'll say this before
um
J energy
foration or consumption um and speaking
the offices I think we should condition
quite reasonable um a scheme of renewal
renewable energy to be submitted of the
Reserve I would to see that added on
as it is it will be supported by the
plan engine planning and energy 2008 so
we should we should have got sufficient
support
you raised in your summary concerns
about
writing be grateful if Som we can
enhance any ligh I
think sugestion to look
at
minimizing LED whatever else is
used
weam
negative
LED I perhaps we could add
add
set
am
beond right other points of
debate cat did you you indicated that
you did you make a proposal that's what
I'm trying to
say
was call you
chills to approve the
application with the additional
conditions that we've done in the debate
and the
update
Improv
we're going back to the vote then okay
can we just again just
all
thank you that's so committee reses
application
19142 right thank you for that we'll go
on to the
next
all
right next application is application
number six
Mayfield
lenion Reserve
matter
15317 EX worksh
elction
asso
appc at Mayfield
fide identified
by The Reserve matters
consider
access as you can see thewell are
aranged fashion
Lanell are
Maxim
are
good evening
gentlemen we can't resist the
development a s in
green particular in the
green the committee that the footprint
of the houses lied 1500
what we want
Tob
sing what we particular concerned on
is the way
down
number buildings four five six and seven
to the east sorry there's a strip of
land which could be open for development
we want to prevent that because that is
green belt land that's just there and we
see no reason why we need that turning
Circle halfway down surely there enough
room between seven and eight to get a
form 360 de turning Circle for a refuge
vehicle with a central island um with so
that you don't have that access to the
between four and four and
five which is a danger of it get coming
out onto the Eastern side and developing
further so we would like to see a full
circle turning 360 de C between unit
seven and eight to prevent that having
to reverse down to number eight which is
acent waiting to happen
in basically that's it we want to
protect the green belt surrounding this
development and we want to make sure
that there's no chance of them coming
further east to that piece of strip of
land which
is
yes
conc
absolutely in a COR I see these vehic
reversing down my regular basis
Danger
the bottom house is number eight and
there's plenty of room between seven and
eight to make a 360
de
dve
I can't see the occup and number Tak ref
that
my you put a at the bottom it could and
it would be much
preferable do we get a condition that
can be no extension to this
development
stre
than
me
already was
a
ref
any to
create
need
off
yes
question
look
impr
looks
for
con
it
minut
e
right thank you for that with us move on
to our next application which is
app
for number of Reas sub
dismissed
have
loated two drop Cur
access
is
look
C
Dev
in
uh chairman counselors the Paris Council
have already raised the numerous
conflicts that this application has with
the core strategy which you'll see in
the agenda I will address some
additional significant local issues the
parish council would support a
development of three small houses on
this site that has always been the
intention since our pre-submission plan
in July 2018 and the applicants are
fully aware of that however the
applicants their consultant and there
the planning officer have continued to
ignore our neighborhood plan they cannot
say that they've been they have not been
consulted the neighborhood plan group
met with the applicants at their behest
in January to discuss the boab and the
site in general this predates the
application by at least five months the
officer states that our NDP is still in
consultation this is incorrect the
regulation 16 consultation ended on the
28th of June and our plan has been
sitting on a desk at Elizabeth house for
the last three months the officer says
that our NDP carries limited weight but
then goes on to rely on it in several
instances either the plan can be relied
on or it can't the officer seems to rely
on it where it serves a purpose purp to
do so he relies on the NDP by saying
that the site is part of an allocated
site if you could put up our first slide
thank you it's actually larger than the
allocated site by some 20% and it
overlaps our proposed
bab which is the green line on that
slide on the western side not the
Eastern side as he says in the report of
the
site if the plan carries little weight
then the site is outside the boab and
outside the village as defined by SDC
and as such by current convention and in
every other case in low so permission
should only be granted if the parish
council and Ward members support it
which they definitely do not however if
the plan is to be relied on then notice
should be taken of the proposed boab and
the site assessment which stipulates
that the site is allocated for three
houses in linear form the officer states
that simply because the current
application has reduced the number of
houses and the site coverage from the
previous unsuccessful application then
it would be unreasonable to conclude
that the new application does not comply
with policies cs15 16 and 10 30 seconds
there is no basis for this statement we
believe the application still conflicts
with those policies in summary if this
application is granted it will make a
mockery of the whole neighborhood plan
process including in our case years of
consultation with the community this
will have a significant impact on tyo
and will resonate in other Villages who
similarly have undertaken the huge
amount of work to produce a plan it will
say that SDC does not take notice of
what the community says and will present
another instance of developers interests
being put ahead of those of the local
community as expressed in a neighborhood
plan thank you did give you slightly way
because I could tell you comeing to the
end so that was spot on thank you very
much uh questions for the councelor
please councelor Mills thanks Michelle
hi David
um so you'll be
happier with with with three just three
smaller dwellings of after so they sort
of stter homes or yes two or three
bedroom along the the front of the road
they're on the the right hand side of
that slide uh the houses are I think
there are three four bedroom houses and
three bedroom and two bedroom from from
memory uh which is way above the core
strategy
recommendation but three houses along
the road Frontage is what we have in the
neighborhood plan and in the site
assessment that's said that's in your
neighborhood plan the um the three
houses is it right yes and you're
waiting for that to be
adopted
you okay Council M was trying to indic
or um what stage of in the process of
the neighborhood plan have you got to
please well as I said earlier the the
regulations you said it ear but I need
clarification I didn't quite understand
sorry I might a little bit dense so can
you bear with me and just clarify in
simple terms regulation 16 consultation
ended on the 28th of
June um we were then expecting expecting
to see the summary of those comments
that we received plus the the district
council's own comments shortly after the
consultation ended we're now three
months down the road and we've not seen
any comments from Stratford we've not
seen any comments from residents and
we're still waiting for those so there
has been a very
large um gap between the consultation
ending and receiving anything back from
the district council okay which is
rather unusual thank you for that but n
explained that which I didn't know fully
at the start from your presentation so
thank you for that and it's also given
me the opportunity to raise fact that
there's been a delay as well so again I
think that's a win-win from that point
of view so thank you for that uh any
further questions for the uh Council
please
celor yeah I'm u in agreement with you
about development in in these sites and
I think there are probably too many
large houses is there a need obviously
in this Village for smaller houses
for people to occupy in a word no um tyo
has a larger than average um
preponderance of four and five bedroom
houses larger than average within the
district what what we're looking for is
two and three bedroom houses
predominantly maybe four bedroom house
but not predominantly for bedroom
houses no I would agree with on
that thank you very much counc free to
you didn't indicate did you go on counc
KW I wish to stop doing that please how
many two one two and three bedroom
houses have been included in the in
developments under the core strategy
would you have a handle on
that uh no not off the top of my head um
most of the sites we have allocated in
the um neighborhood plan would give us a
variety of houses we also have a site a
large site which would give us
affordable houses of two and three
bedrooms I don't have the the exact
number off the top of my head
though the third and final time you are
free to go
now right uh can we have Mr Keith Risk
please I think it's the gentleman in the
green cou who's just coming yeah here he
is thank you thank
you again Mr R you got three
minutes May
of put your microphone on please sorry
there a point of order Mr chairman may I
just before the time starts I I would
like just to say that uh I've been asked
by 27 other residents of liso to speak
on their behalf so I'm appearing not
just on my own behalf but on their
behalf as well y thank you so far away
when you're ready would you like a
warning 30 seconds yes please good man
thank you very much for away thank
you uh councelors and chairman and
counselors key Strat to the statford
course strategy are the role and
historic character and local
distinctiveness of the district will be
maintained and enhanced this application
meets none of these key
objectives The Proposal differs little
from that for seven houses on this site
dismissed at appeal it would be Suburban
style backfill not infield development
almost indistinguishable from the act
design rejected in the appeal it would
differ entirely from the linear form of
housing in the hamlet it would result in
new access roads we all consider a
danger in this section of Lower tyo Road
it would breach key core strategy
planning policy
principles there is no dispute that the
orchard site is in Lower tyo A distinct
rural settlement some distance from the
lsv of tyo the application site is 890 M
from the lsv services sdc's criteria
consider this to be unsustainably remote
the planning officer's recommendation
relies heavily on the inspector's
comment in The Orchards appeal because
the reasons for dismissal were not on
the grounds of sustain unsustainability
and state that the site conforms with
cs-15 that is not right in the appeal
for the Orchards the inspector states
that there is also a local bus service
linking lower and middle tyo it was on
this basis that he did not share the
council's view that the site location is
unsustainable he is wrong there is no
such bus service contrast this with a
more recent appeal at the Willows
directly opposite the oras where the
inspector states that being over half a
million kilometer from the lsv services
of tyo is
unsustainable both he and the inspector
for another more recent Lowa tyo appeal
at home Holdings agree that development
in low tyo is subject to as10 a policy
not even mentioned in the Orchard's
appeal this supports small scale
developments with when within the
physical confines of an L lsv not when
in the open Countryside if approved this
application would lead to a planning
nonsense that one site in lower tyo
meets the provisions of cs15 and as10
While others do not lower tyo can't be
carved up like this it is a distinct
Hamlet settlement in all planning
applications for lower tyo SDC has
concluded that its Rural and distinct
character and distance from the lsv of
Tao mean that these policies apply with
a presumption against development if
this is approved that policy presumption
would change removing limits on
development and creating a presumption
in favor of development this would
potentially allow Market housing
throughout the physical confines of the
settlement of lower Daiso this would
destroy not enhance form character and
local dis
distinctiveness councilors there either
are planning principles govering lower
tyo or there aren't we think there are
as10 and cs15 these polic principle
should not allow this application to be
approved any benefit the development
would bring would be materially
outweighed by the harm caused in
breached of fundamental aims of the nppf
thank you very much a few extra seconds
because I'll see you better to finish um
right any questions for Mr R
please councelor
Ms thanks good evening even have the has
tyo reach its um housing allocation
number or not
yet uh has built no it has not built the
housing number that was expected in the
core strategy okay this thank you and
also um were there any consultation from
the with the with the parish council is
there any consultation uh as I
understand it the uh there was
consultation with the parish council
okay
thanks
con um the draft NDP even though it has
been through
the process that was described by coun
roach
um defines this is suitable for three
houses where do
you sit with that with all 27
residents uh councelor I I can't speak
for all 27 residents on that we do know
that a number of residents of lower tyo
quite a significant number of residents
of low tyo are very uncomfortable with
the proposal for that site in the NDP
for precisely the reasons I've just
given yeah I think I was going to touch
on that as well I think that if I heard
you correctly and my hearing is
gradually going as I get a bit older um
you sort of said it was like an
unsustainable unsuitable location
because the bus service that was there
in the inspector's uh report is not
there is that right correct yeah so go
move that so therefore um from Tao's
point of view the parish council they
must have thought it was the sustainable
side because they would have been happy
with three homes there so I think
there's some
slight slight difference there of
opinion yes sir there is a difference uh
uh the difference is between those of us
who feel that basic conditions of the
cor strategy we Beed in the neighborhood
plan that does not seem to be a view
taken by either the barish council or
The Neighborhood Planning Group okay
that's fine I just wanted to clarify so
that's that's clarified it that's great
thank you much any more questions for Mr
risk right you're free to go sir thanks
very
much and our next speaker is Mr Steve
Tyler
please uh you've got six minutes Mr
Tyler feel free when you're far away
when you're ready and we'll give you a
warning with about 30 seconds okay
thanks evening
everyone uh right the starting this site
is as you've heard it is an allocated
site in the emerging neighborhood
plan in the previous inspector's report
on a scheme for seven houses the
inspector found in favor of the
applicants on three out of four CS his
only problem with it was the design and
layout of the site importantly he found
that the whole of the site including the
blue bit at the back to be suitable for
development and policy compliance with
cs15 cs16 and
as10 so the
policy compliance issue is not an issue
the inspector has ruled on this it is
policy
compliant the approach we've taken to
the site is to try and work towards the
neighborhood PL position by reducing the
site in size and safeguarding the land
at the back for um a combination of
Orchard land and uh Wildlife Area and
reducing the site itself to the cage rad
that you
show
um and we have also in in addition to
this
um we've maintained all significant
trees on the site where the previous
scheme uh proposed to take most of them
out we've removed the cisac layout which
is what the object the the principal
objection of the inspector
was and we worked within the existing
build lines at the front and at the
rear um we've designed traditional
houses in hon Stone and slate and
significantly we put the parking of the
road Frontage properties to the rear of
the properties so that when viewed from
the A andb on the opposite side of the
road you can't see lots of par cars what
you'll see is a row Stone haunted Stone
Cottages
um immediately opposite the houses that
we're proposing you'll see that there
are a loose knit arrangement of um
houses that are either off Shar drives
or set back off the road so we are
actually following the prevailing built
form indeed uh Mr risk you've just heard
from owns two houses directly opposite
the site both of which are off of shared
access which is exactly what we're
proposing on this
side um we agreed with the inspector
that the previous scheme for seven was
completely wrong for the site it
consisted of basically a two lane
Highway into the site with a huge
turning head all in tarmac with seven
houses group round it all inward facing
turning their backs on the road
generally totally out of keeping with
tyo so we've worked closely with your
senior planning officer to redesign the
scheme so that we get the day out dead
right it's a large site it can easily
accommodate five houses and um we feel
that by changing the application during
the process of working with the officer
we've come up with a scheme that is
ideal for this
site
um in addition to that by working
closely with the planner we've met all
the highway
requirements we've amended the designs
for the parking as I've already said uh
we've met all the requirements
concerning separation distance and
visual
amenity um and we've
basically produced some designs that are
totally in line with the district design
guide um in fact some of the houses have
been U built in other locations in a and
in Conservation Area so they're clearly
acceptable in in design
terms um and I think I have to agree
with the officer's conclusion at the end
of your uh report which is is that in
line with the inspector's conclusions
this application should be determined in
line with development plan
policies uh and again the officer can
identify no material considerations that
warrant taking any other
approach so I strongly recommend that
you go with the officer on this one and
hopefully back the uh
application if there are any other
questions you'd like to put to me
regarding design your off I'm more than
happy to
answer can you put the um microphone on
please counc bar there's a picture of
there yes where the tennis assum the
applicant so where the tennis cour is
and you can see the prevailing built
form immediately
opposite yeah and the prevailing built
form on the right hand side of the road
is all within the a whereas this site is
not
understand yeah that's fine counc that's
fine counc Mo see you indicating thank
you um in developing the site we were
you aware as developers of the emerging
neighborhood plan were they just wanted
three houses there yes absolutely but In
fairness the development plan although
the consultation is finished it's still
subject to change and many inspectors
have made the point that whilst it is
subject to change it carries limited
weight now
we're you know agreed that it should be
developed as does the neighborhood plan
but we think it should be developed more
in line with the inspector's
observations than purely a line of
houses along the road it's clear from
the aerial photograph that this is this
surrounding Bel form is not just limited
to linear development so why should the
neighborhood plan limit this to
Neighborhood de to um linear development
and also I mean um councelor roach made
a point about the housing mix well the
majority of houses on this site are two
and three bedroom which is precisely
what they're asking for in the
neighborhood
plan there's one two bedroom two two
three bedrooms a four-bedroom and a
five-bedroom so a good across theboard
mix to meet the housing requirements of
tyo which incidentally in relation to
your initial question earlier on the the
target figure for tyo was 85 houses and
only 35 have been approved or built so
far so there's a clear shortfall in
housing and
tyon right I've got a question for you
right it's two part one were you
involved in the original application
that was refused uh no I wasn't right
that might explain that's why I don't
like it yeah because obviously you you I
was about to say you AG you know agreed
with the the seven not being appropriate
so therefore but You' just answered that
question so
right any further questions for Mr
terer no right you free to go okay thank
you thank you and we've now got the ward
member C the
Fielding okay so the Fielding you've got
five minutes if you could uh just before
you start can we have also I will want
the one that shows the the roadside
wall that that one yeah but can you
start with the
plan right you've got five minutes far
away councelors um you've heard the
concerns of the parish council with the
effects of housing allocation that they
have set in the neighborhood plan this
neighborhood plan has been some years in
the making and has caused
a lot of discussions within the Parish
of
Tao um the builtup area was
drawn up it shows when the sorry when
the builtup area boundary was drawn up
it showed that part of the site of of
the field of the land fell within the
area plot four and five are on the
border between the A andb and the rest
of the garden land and therefore should
not be developed on the side of the land
is a stone
wall that runs along the roadside with
Conifer hedge topping the wall this
provides the roadside boundary to the
site and the plans show that this wall
is to be demolished in two places to
allow for Access onto the site this
would damage this roadside
feature an entrance to the site should
be created to the southern end of the
wall at the junction between the
approved go back to
the um the approved
site um and the and the current site for
development this would allow um the
application this would allow the road to
run behind the three houses which front
onto the road as suggested by the
inspector the house on the side on the
opposite side of the road have their
driveways running behind the dwellings
toot the officer
cs15 if I can get that
up
um States the development in the local
Services Village will take place on
sites identified within the neighborhood
plan which this is and those small scale
developments on unidentified land but
suitable sites within the be the builtup
area boundary or otherwise within their
confines the three houses referred to in
the neighborhood come within
cs15
the of other parts of cs15 as on page 84
of the core strategy shouldn't be note
noted as to harm that this scheme would
have with lower
tyo um if I can get to that I will read
it
out um in relation to to the res
residential developments the number of
houses proposed is consistent with the
overall scale of the development
identified for the settlement the site
the scale of the development is
appropriate to the immediate
surroundings and to the overall size of
the character of the settlement this
refers in a in my view to the houses on
the opposite side which
are of character of stone and
keep the the overall impression of cs15
and the
Village um cs10 small scale schemes for
housing employment of community
facilities to meet a need identified by
the local community this this is not as
such identified by the local community
but it is in the neighborhood plan and
therefore large houses should not be
included and should be within the scale
as discussed earlier on with councelor
roach small house scale housing schemes
including the Redevelopment of buildings
within the builtup area boundary of a of
a local or otherwise within the physical
confines to Accord to the policy of cs15
of which we have have just raised the
matter I think that we should be looking
at the three houses along the frontage
of the road no gaps in that wall because
otherwise you're going to create parking
feeding into those Cottages along the
front there so therefore the road should
and perhaps should also take into
account the developed site or the the
site on the southern Edge that has been
given planning
permission uh and that is my
submission C fil well within the five
minutes any questions for the ward
member
no I've got got El I've got a couple as
well so thanks Michelle
um John I I can't quite follow you that
the if it was just three on the front
just if it was just three houses yes
sorry where would hearing behind a bit
louder where would their access be where
would you want their access where that
that refers to the Cy with planning
permission on the southern end approve
been approved um there is a stream a
ditch there but that could be overcome
and that would be a better it
unfortunately what we want and what we
have in front of us is totally different
we can only discuss what we've got in
front of us some Frid but I appreciate
that the end of the wall happens at that
point and I don't want to see thatall
damage because he's a very important
feature of the roadside that's fine now
you clarified that but we've got to
stick to what we got in front of but I
can understand understand where you come
from on that one there's plenty of WR
there right I've got a couple of
questions um the size the house is
opposite um which according to Mr
T said they were in the I and
potentially owned by Mr risk um again
allegedly potentially I'm carefully
choosing my words here um do you know
how big those houses are are in terms of
number of bedrooms I don't but there are
two or three owners RIS has one Mr Mr CA
has another and then there is a house up
behind which is a converted bar and
others but they are set back okay
and no this point for clarification I'll
I'll come back to the officers on that
one thank you K the
barns well in what you just said these
three houses if they were along the road
the other two which you're objecting to
they they look to be the same distance
as the houses on the opposite side of
the road at away from the road is that
no they're much further away from from
the
road can field and you're free to go
thank
you right the points of clarification
with
offices C
jit could you just clarify for me the um
regulation 16 stage just to be uh that
everybody understands at what stage the
NDP is
at so yeah it's a regulation 16 um so
until it's formally adopted it carries
limited weight so in our assessment it
it would have limited weight until it's
formally
adopted um I've got a point um again
it's to do with the
NDP
um I might be putting words in councelor
roach's mouth um Brie sort of indicated
that SDC was cherry picking parts of the
NDP that suited us and was ignoring bits
that didn't can you just give us your VR
that please is that right C yes thank
you okay so the two slides in front of
you um I should stress have both have
limited weight so the one on the left
hand side is our site allocation plan
buil a Parry boundary and that has a
boundary for um middle and upper tyo so
it the application site itself Falls
outside of our defined buila Parry
boundary that's still a consultation
station that's still got limited weight
um the the plan on the right hand side
is where the application site is and
that's within the NDP so the NDP has it
partly within uh their built a Parry
boundary some of the land to the left
hand side of that that black line
there is is included within the
application site so it's not wholly
within their buila a boundary uh but it
is part of their allocation as well uh
so number one there um is an allocation
for approximately three
dwellings just find that it's not in our
perspective boab that we're
proposing but it's partly in the one at
tyo in their
NDP yes that's correct um it's probably
also worth noting that when the
inspector did consider this matter in
the previous application which this was
the site for the previous seven so this
um the the left hand side here was in
the red line um so when the inspector
considered that plan he did look at um
the policies our appeal statement that
went along to the inspector did refer to
our core strategy policies but the
inspector considered that the principle
of development in this location was
acceptable thank you coun CLE
I'm slightly confused by that
response given the number of times I've
sat in planning committees and heard
officers say in um
nor lighthorn North End napton that
proposed properties were outside the
boab therefore should not be accepted uh
even though the boab and we're talking
two years ago was very much further
behind where we are today you're now
arguing uh that the complete the
converse argument that the bab should
now be given limited weight when Mr
Barker has sat in that probably the very
same chair and said we should be taking
into account the by in fact Matthew in
North End you argued not very long ago a
property should be refus permission
because it sat outside the bab uh and
you and I had a disagreement on that and
the committee um made its decision
accordingly if I then go to inspection's
decision um I've got it here paragraph
14 the council argues that lower coun
lower T should not currently be regarded
as forming part of tyo for the purposes
of Cs CS policies 15 and
16 instead because lower tyo is
separated from middle tyo by over Open
Fields um it should be considered part
of the open Countryside and that
decision was reinforced I think an
appeal decision of Home Holdings as well
as as and I'm not quite sure about the
Willows case I think that's on the other
side of the road so we do seem to have
Matthew and your you sat and told me in
North End that a property absolutely
banged next to the B boundary should be
refused because it was just outside that
boundary and yet here we have the
council boab boundary quite a long way
away and you're saying we should ignore
it if mayor um there's two tests so
policy as10 which is our Countryside and
Villages policy does talk about built a
par boundaries but they have to be
defined so at the moment the site
locations plan is in draft form so it's
only limited weight so they're not
actually defined yet so it goes on to
the second test which is the physical
confines test in the North End case that
you're talking about the application
site fell north of the village The
Willows Cas again for example is here
which was considered to fall outside the
physical confines of the settlement um
so in this case the inspectors obviously
reviewed policy cs15 cs16 and has looked
at it as a whole and determined that
this is an acceptable location for
development I have to disagree with that
Matthew because you actually said in
north end it was outside the boab and
the committee decided that it was within
the physical confines so we have to have
consistency in this committee and I'm
I'm afraid Mr chairman I have have a raw
problem when we have officers arguing
two or three years ago that being
outside the draft Bob was good reason to
refuse and yet we now have saying the B
carries a limited weight uh when in fact
it has been through um about complete
final consultation which is purely
related to three issues and that is
whether it is legal whether it is in
line with the duty to cooperate and
whether it is sound the vabs have been
through two full consultations
beforehand and we are now at a very very
final stage and now to take a reverse
view of boab boundaries this application
contrary to where we have had only two
months ago with Mr coin uh and in many
other cases I have a real problem with
that can we please have consistency and
I'd like this taken forward outside this
meeting as well but we cannot have this
variation some in some out chairman I
think we can be absolutely consistent
here um we can chase this round all
night uh arguing about different sites
discussing different sites and different
judgments that we made which of course
we don't have any evidence on in front
of us but what we do have which is very
very clear is the view of an inspector
who was recently said this is within the
built form of the village and therefore
it's suitable for development and that
should be given great weight and that's
where the consistency is coming from
chairman yeah I must that was the the
thing I was going to raise the fact that
has been examined in public by an
inspector who's is in the built form
um um so I think we have moved on and
this case is different to the ones we
mentioned before but accept the point we
do need some clarity when we go forward
and I've asked Ross to make a note of
this so we we can talk about this uh
outside the meeting um but I was of the
opinion um and I would agree with the
offices in this case don't always agree
with them that has it's been examined in
public plan inspect he says it's
acceptable as a built form area um I
will be happy to go along with with
their opinion on this
one should we go to the debate I think
we well I think we can then discuss
where are we with the NDP which limits
it to three um three houses has been
through a full public
consultation uh and this application is
for five against three which is quite a
significant difference I would argue
that the NDP hasn't been examined in
public yet where the
application um was examined by the
inspector so I think that's where there
is some of the difference there but
perhaps I'm putting words into D
Matthew's so I don't want to come back
on that
one CH I've taken the advantage the the
opportunity while you're talking of
looking up the pro the stages of an NDP
and regulation 16 is the publicizing of
the NDP proposal where the local
planning Authority publicize it on its
website
um for a period of no less than six
weeks uh following that there's a stage
where an NDP is appoint is appoints an
examiner the local planning Authority
rather uh appoints an examiner submits a
plan for examination and it's only
following that and several other stages
that an NDP is made and it's only at
that point NDP gets full weight so at
the moment the NDP doesn't have full
weight and you should not be giving it
full weight it's indicative of the the
wishes of the village but it does not
have full
weight so that presumably applies to the
allocation of this site in its
entirety yes
correct apart from the fact that it's
been considered by an
inspector who who who found the
principle of development acceptable I
agree Ross but there have been other
appeal sites as well at the Willows and
at home Holdings both of which have
identify that this uh settlement being
not part of tyo which is the ls not the
lsv it is the lsv um it is a separate
settlement and both the other inspectors
felt it was too remote so we've got
three inspector's decisions two of which
have felt that properties in this part
are actually too far away but we have an
inspector rep on this this actual
site got three three inspector reports
for the same
settlement chairman uh you've heard
councelor kettle's views you've heard
officer's views uh it's appropriate for
members to debate this matter and to
make a decision there is nothing I can
add uh the inspector made his views
quite clear uh and and that is the only
advice I can give
you C fool and you've indicated but you
can come back but only with a matter of
fact if you can clarify a point it's not
a comment you can't make a comment
you've got to clarify the fact um
clarify that there has been a lot of
discussion within the neighborhood and
the parish and the neighborhood plan has
been discussed at length by the parish
yeah okay that's fine um so just so I
can again make sure we're clear on this
the plan inspector is saying this is an
era for
development the NDP with its limited
weight is saying it's an area for
development but with up to three houses
up to that line so therefore they are
saying
that they agree with the principle of
dment on that site but not quite to the
extent uh of the inspector and the the
applicant yeah that is correct right I
don't do that very often thank you go k
k very briefly the second point I have
to come from the inspect report is he
specifically identifies that um this is
a rural setting um yet it's CAC this
relating to previous applications CAC Le
is more typical of a Suburban rather
than this distinct rural environment and
yet we've got exactly the same type of
design of a CAC here and that goes back
to the the comments earlier on about
look at a linear format so would you
agree that this is in uh conflict with
the inspector's recommendations in
paragraph
six uh not specifically no so the the
previous application had a number of
design flaws with it um I'll just go
back to the site layout plan I don't
have the actual house types here in
front of me tonight but um there was a
range of house types it was all inward
facing so it proposed a separate access
into the site which was um je jeal width
um all the houses along this part of the
site fronted to the uh West so it was
all in Wood facing so the backs of these
properties for fronted the road um
there's also a number of design issues
with the properties themselves uh they
weren't particularly in keeping with the
overall character of the area um so the
applicants have
again sorry again the other issue was
that it spred into this part of the site
up here so with the new site
layout it's it's restricted so there is
a build line there um so previously
there was the house came into this bit
of land here um the properties now front
the road so they address that road the
parking has been put to the rear uh the
individual house types which I'll just
go back
to are considered to be fairly
traditional for the locality so whil
I mean it's down to members tonight to
decide whether or not they want to
Define that as a coldi sack of
development but it's whether or not that
one issue um raised by the inspector on
four different design grounds is enough
to uh result in a reason for refusal I
think if I could just add to that chair
um I think it's fair to say that when
Matthew first showed this site to me I
challenged him on exactly that point so
Council Kettle yet you you are raising
exactly the right point and um Matthew
responded in very the way responded
tonight to me um and and when I look at
it I can see that there are fundamental
differences between this and the scheme
that was was previously considered as
Matthew says firstly the first three
houses face onto the road in exactly the
way you would expect them to do so in a
village uh the other two
houses they are built behind the first
three and if you look at the proposal I
don't know whether I can point it out to
you mostly point to
gos if you if you look you can see the
allall is proposed along here and also
along this side most of the way along it
will have more of a character of a rural
Village than of an open plan Suburban uh
CCT and that's the difference between
this and the other one I'm not
suggesting that this is some sort of
paragan of design um but it has that
character of Rural
Street right I think we all move points
of clarification or divite can I can I
just seek some clarification that about
the land at the back it was talked about
that that should become um more tree
planting more biodiversity in that area
is does that is that covered by a
condition that that will
happen
yes so there is um conditions relating
to Landscaping in there um condition I
recommend yeah and eight relates to
ecological mitigation and enhancement
measures as well WCC County mology are
happy with that as well and also
protection of retain trees and hedges
number
10 y right I think we've uh clarified
this one to
death um we need to go on to the debate
this points to clarification
C good thank you good right far away put
your microphone on
please I have a I have a real problem
with this application
um we seem and I I think very much
Council roach's point being taken that
we we we get we've gone a support from
it from the
NDP um which is acknowledged as being in
its adopted form um the bab which as I'm
sure all council is aware have reached
its final stage this site is not in the
buav uh and therefore on the track
record of officers anything outside the
bab should be ignored uh I think that's
a bit harsh counc Kettle um could you
clarify your point about track record of
offices I don't think could really
defend themselves through it I think
that's a bit unfair okay I'll withdraw
that comment and I'll have another go
sorry I found this kind of line um not
the way that we conduct our S I have
withdrawn the comment councilor
Jun there have been a number of cases
recently where the boab has been
considered a defining
Factor um in suggesting
refusal um is that acceptable councelor
junor um the NGP if we do take it on
board has restricted this to three
properties the inspector in his report
talks about um cesac type approach being
inappropriate for this
setting and I disagree with um Dale if I
may in that his view is it is um a
different design to the one that was
refused by the inspector I don't feel
confident with that I think the way is
laid out with a road coming behind the
fronted fronted houses is very similar
to the previous one and there does form
in my view a c SEC which inspector was
not comfortable
with so I think on those grounds I would
be proposed to re refuse this
application and go against officer
recommendations okay and I apologize for
my earlier comment which as I said I
have I think we we do have to be careful
in what language we are using
I can you apologize and withdrawn it and
then the terms you're using after your
apologies off were more appropriate to
the conversation I've got no problems
with members disagreeing with offices
that's what we're here for but it's just
the way we disagree with them so I think
you know we apologize and we move on but
can we bear that in mind in future
debates and conversations
please let minut SCH isn't
it so right cancel Mills I'm sure you'll
be okay yeah thanks Mr chairman
um to be honest I'm not comfortable with
this I mean um I know is an emerging
neighborhood development plan and he has
got limited weight but is an emerging
plan and all along
they the Steering group um of one of
these three houses
um okay move on approximately three
could be four could be one or could be
two
um right so I'm I'm not comfortable with
this uh Mr chairman um so um I I will
see what the uh all the other members
have say about it but I'm not
comfortable with it thank you C
bars
well there is obviously a lot of
concern but this is in the plan the
neighborhood plan we really in whether
it's three or
five um and whether there's two bedroom
houses because that's what the parish
want Parish did say there would be a big
site somewhere in the village which
would have affordable homes so in that
respect if that's what some of the
people want obviously they could be done
there uh with the inspector's report I
can't I can understand the concern but
looking at the we did have that photo I
liked and try to find out where the site
was it is
a Mitch Match of AES in different places
and different distances from the road so
I personally can't see it being out of
place I understand I've got two parishes
that have written in about the reserve
sites they have done their Parish plan
they can't get it back
either no way can they get the district
council to come back you know so they're
thinking well I wonder why but as far as
I'm concerned in planing terms although
there is
objections uh they look okay to
me coun J you it we have to consider
this um strictly on um planning terms
and material considerations and what uh
weight we put on various decisions and
it's been clearly outl lined that um the
weight that we have to put on uh the
inspector's decision and the weight that
we have to put on the NDP uh we can't go
against the weight that is is that that
that has another another year and it
might have been very different but
that's the way it is at the moment and
we have to go with what is the
law ccor
Fleming I've been on both sides of the
NDP whether it's been made or whether it
hasn't um and we've lost decisions when
it hasn't been made and we've won
decisions when it has and coupled with
the fact that um they haven't achieved
half of what the allowance for houses
was we talked about 85 and
37 um because the the NDP isn't made and
because we still have this shortfall and
whatever um I would be more of a mind to
support on the basis again of what uh
Susan's saying about how we wake this
NDP
situation um so from that perspective I
would be more of a mood uh to support
this rather than uh rather than object
right so just
clarify we've had was yours a proposal
to
refuse um we've sort of had a half of
support from Council M but we weren't
sure
um are you willing to
Second so we've got a proposal from
Council CLE seconded by Council minals
to refuse the application so we'll go to
the vote on that one all those in favor
of refusing the
application yeah well the reason I heard
counselor was the cisac design
essentially was was your reason for
refusal and cisac design and
insufficient weight been given to the um
site allocation plan which is currently
out at the end of consultation period
and and and the
NDP
delegations
plan could you clarify the second reason
just so we can check that it's robust um
firstly you're correct in that the
design still fails to meet the the
inspector's uh previous comments on uh
paragraph six of his report and secondly
that insufficient wage is being given to
the both the um bab as part of the site
allocation plan which excludes the site
and the NDP which limits the site having
three properties not
five so if I can pardon me chair if I
can just clarify that a little further
your your reason for your reason for
refusal counselor is that the appliation
is outside the builtup area boundary for
lower tier as proposed in the emerging
site allocations plan and the
emerging neighborhood development plan
no I'm saying in the neighborhood
development plan and side allocation
plan and the B and the bo both excludes
the
side um the nebor development plan isn't
that what I said how was what you said
different the
NDP
boundary limits this site to three
properties not
five okay all right and the second point
I I fully understood that that c design
you feel is too Urban and not not
appropriate in this rural location
correct I think the wording was you
heard there was that the NDP limits this
site to to three but I I understood
elsewhere that it was not limited to
three but it was the wording was about
um so I
think um right so
we've we've had a proposal we've had a
seconder we've clarified the reasons for
refusal so we'll go to the vote on that
proposal all those in favor of refusing
to Chairman those
against five
chairman so Committee just so we now
need I will propose approval and have we
a second of that councelor
junid
so any conditions on this one any other
additional conditions we've put in
or none in the upate is there
um if the committee is minded to support
it I think need to ensure there is a um
construction management plan in
place are you happy to accept that c the
BS accept you're happy to accept a
condition of construction management
plan in
place yeah no just have to go through
the
problem sorry chair could I ask for
further clarification what the
construction management plan needs to
cover they're very broad
normally
opening time I don't know where this is
compared with the school other
facilities in the village there may be a
nursery school but those are the sort of
things that need to be incorporated in
Egypt can we delegate that to
officers can I can I raise the issue to
us yes you can you can delegate the
precise wording to offices for the
construction thank you can I just raise
the issues concern there have been two
other developments on this St s
structure Road um one of which has
caused considerable group local
residents um with with Builders Vehicles
being parked on the road with lorries
bringing materials in parking on the
road uh with mud being taken off sites
onto the road um which has been I know a
matter of major concern if you could
clarify those points by email to the
officers so they can take that into
account when they come up with the
formal words for the construction
management plan we can take all all
evidence into
account I mean I think we put that point
now I think we we'll move on we'll be
here all night otherwise I've got six
houses opposite of school we lost on
appeal the Builder has been very good in
fact he' probably been better than the
parents on getting the construction plan
done because they wanted as much as so I
don't have a problem
y right well we'll go to the vote now um
Can B proposed can
second all those in favor of agreement
to Grant application
19529 F please
V all those in
favor five chairman those
against n chairman
abstentions two chairman
two are you
against so just clarify that you're
against so it's five in favor one
against and one abion
right so committee resolves to Grant
application
F thank you very much move on to the
next
application
right um before we move on to the next
item we are getting perly close to the
3-hour cut off point at quarter 9
um I need members to agree or disagree
that we carry on after quarter past 9
I'm proposing that we do so
we can we just any all those in favor
can we just clarify that
y okay
well y okay next item 19
sl1312 F armale green L Knoxville
demolition existing prefab Bulow
erection of new for bedroom dwelling and
Joe is our presenting
officer thank you chair the site is
located on the edge of Fox Hill as
indicated by the black dot on the plan
before
you the application site relates to a
single dwelling known as armdale the
site is situated off Green Lane with the
immediate street scene comprising of a
number of development ties and variety
of mats the site has an existing access
off Green Lane and has a large parking
area to the front of the
property this is an area with long green
a uh I please note the varying Styles
and plot sizes see application site AR
line in red and the neighboring dings
along long green
line This is a block plan exist and also
help demonstrates the varying plot size
and designs with the immediate context
of the site fale is located to West the
application 18 M Beyond The Bungalow and
has a ridge height of 8 m immedic to the
east is a two story wing of the paddu
with a ridge height of seven M so I
think that's Ferndale 8 m padex 7 m
Brandon is a one story Bungalow which
you'll see further
on this is the proposed block plan for
the new
dwelling the application is proposing a
ridge height of 7.5 M with predominant
white render with an area gray bricks to
rear and side
elevations this is the rear side
elevations you can see see the fitration
detail on proposed
materials this is the Bungalow that is
existing at the minute and being
proposed to be replaced as you can see
the neighboring Bungalow there is an
adjacent field
access these are developments located to
the uh west of the principal elevation
so that's to Ferndale with the 8 m Ridge
height these are set at um 1 met Ridge
height about 6.8 which I've referenced
in my
report this is the field access but
please not as you can see the BOS here
this is the twostory wing immediately
Jason regarding the two
dwellings and that's the padd with the
two story Wings Over
side this is the start of green l so the
PCT is situated here and you can see
there's a twostory dwelling right at the
start but I do there is obviously a
reasonable gap between the two St
between the
dwellings that's why end the
presentation based on the existing
Street seeing neighboring properties and
the variety of materials designed of
heights along long Green Lane offers a
recommendation is for approval on the
update sheet you will see there was one
further representation made by campaign
for Tech rural England which I
summarized within the update sheet
thanks
chair thank you chair can have first
speaker please which is councelor Derek
Harbor and apologize for keeping you so
long councelor
haror and thank you for bearing with
us three minutes far away when you're
ready and we'll give you a warning with
30 seconds to
go thank you chairman counselors thank
you for giving me the chance to
speak the reasons that we're objecting
uh basically around the most of the core
strategies so core strategy 9
3.8.4 uh I quote local residents and
communities should be involved in the
design the PC as a represented of the
community has not been contacted or
involved by the developer and several
residents as you've seen have objected
the proposed development cs9 a quote
should complement through sensitive
sighting layout and high quality design
in a different concept different context
this may well be a high quality design
but is not to its context cs20 C The
Proposal is three times bigger than the
existing property 71 square meters to
over 200 225 I think this contravenes
the not significantly larger element of
this core
strategy I understand that the thinking
behind cs20 is not that just the village
of oxhill but the whole of Stratford
District I think we're seeing this is
tyo needs two and three bedroom houses
and by tearing one down replacing with a
much larger one the stock of smaller
properties is diminishing I am concerned
that the plan has not given sufficient
weight to this
matter
cs201 proposals will preserve and
enhance the character of the locality
and will not unacceptably detract from
communities of any neighboring property
by reason of loss of daylight loss of
privacy overshadowing or
overbearing I think you can see from the
uh picture that's now on the screen it's
very much overbearing the Bungalow
between the two uh looks very sad indeed
cs202 proposals for new dwellings should
help achieve sustainable mixed
communities by contributing to the
provision of mix of housing to meet
local needs our adopted local Parish
Council sorry Parish plan calls for more
two and three bedroom
houses parking on Drive parking is much
too limited for property of the proposed
size and parking on the highway in this
location would be very very dangerous
according to published parking standards
require three parking spaces and even
with the picture that has been shown
there's clearly not enough room to
accommodate this requirement without the
cars having to reverse onto a road with
blind
spots Parish plan I refer to design and
development guidelines in the parish
plan which has been adopted by SDC and
quote as follows local residents in the
main want to see smaller homes which
cater for both smaller families and for
older people to downsize 30 seconds
please hence guideline n new development
proposals should be based primarily on a
need for smaller homes providing
flexible accommodation and should
exhibit a high standard of
design conclusion the developer is
relying wholly on the precedent set by
fale the large building and totally
regarding adopted core strategy policies
and the parish plan an unsatisfactory
development does not set a precedent
which should be allowed to outweigh
other clear policy conflicts thank you
very much just gave me a little few
extra seconds to finish and you were
very good there thank you very much
canor right any questions
please um the street scene um obviously
on the the pictures and boxing um it
seems little bit of a mix um especially
when you see the one to the left
ofo um could you just give a little bit
more information of your opinion of the
streets SE in that that area please
yes you're absolutely right it is a uh a
mixed set and uh the the parish is happy
with a mixed set the villagers are not
happy with Ferndale they uh many people
wish that Ferndale hadn't been um it's
the nickname The Shard in the village
and uh the one that's been proposed is
sh to because it's certainly marginally
smaller you for that that didn't make me
smile so K the
kettle um the
highways has raised no objection to
um the the design of that um and you're
in Conflict to that have you got any
evidence justest why they might be
wrong I think look at the plan there's
only one way in and one way out so if
you drive in forwards you have to
reverse out and reversing out onto a
Lane I believe is um not preferred
approach something on page
102 um impact on highway safety WCC
raised no objection to the application
subject to conditions requiring a
surface B the cut material for 5 M from
the edge of the highway for the driveway
and turning area that's that's what is
do I I read that as well but if you go
back to the plan that Joe put up showing
the uh the
U yes that one there how is a car going
to get in turn around and come out again
forwards no that's fa just just clarify
that thank you
right thank you coun haror you're free
to
go next speaker is Mark Tippets
please got three minutes Mr Tippets
apologies for keeping you so
long
he register to
speak we're just going to clarify
something only people who
are registered to
speak
yeah okay we' we've clarified that so Mr
L so far away you we just have to make
sure and keep it simple for somebody
simple like me thank
you um Hello thank you uh for letting us
speak and put forward our support
statement for the new four bedroom
dwelling at um Armadale my name is Alex
Lane I'm representing tibet's
development who are current owners of
the site and in conjunction with them
have put together the design for the
replacement dwelling um we were fully
aware the sensitivity of the demolition
of the existing property within the
village and to this end decided it would
be advantageous to engage the local
Authority from the outset a preat was
submitted so as to gauge thoughts on the
design being proposed the report had
indicated at the time of the writing
that District Council had not adopted a
bab um for oill and that furthermore a
neighborhood development plan had yet to
emerge this in conjunction with the
cabinets endorsed draft Bill upara
boundary meeting on the 30th of October
2017 had given weight to endorsing the
council's approach to
ensuring consistency when making
decisions on physical confines of any
settlement in this instance it's
indicated that the site we are speaking
of is within the the bab of ox Hill
preap had highlighted concerns over the
initial two-story design and whilst the
original design was in the former
two-story dwelling in latter revisions
and as part of this planning application
the overall height has been reduced
revised scheme sees the dwelling is a a
story and a half in height and some um 8
in lower than Ferndale the nearest
family home to our plot the dwelling has
been reduced in length at the rear
aspect feature canopy has been removed
along with a more simplified material
pallet than that previously
proposed um policy cs20 section c of the
core strategy States renovating existing
dwellings is often more sustainable
environmentally friendly approach than
replacing existing dwellings in their
entirety where the existing dwelling is
not considered suitable for attention
the replacement dwelling will be that
will be well cited in relation to the
existing site buildings not V visually
intrusive and significantly larger than
the delling it
replaces policy cs20 also sets out
various requirements for proposals of
this type of building but not limited to
the need to preserve and enhance the
character of the locality and need to
take into account other material
considerations we have understood the
council's policy is to allow replacement
dwellings as long as there is more than
a passing nod to the existing Street
Scene and to the dwelling that it
replaces whilst the new dwelling will be
larger than that it replaces we fill the
new one half design matches the existing
Bungalow in terms and materials but
gives the modern day family a generously
spaced home environment it's worth
noting there are a number of
contemporary dwellings along the length
of Green Lane and we feel that Armadale
has been significantly significantly
simplified to tie in with the local
authorities wishes but also to draw on
the existing schemes within the vicinity
policy cs9 of the core strategy states
that the new development will be
expected to compl enance the character
of its context through sensitive
sighting layout and high quality design
so State development should contribute
positively to an area's Char character
and
identity um the above is also enshrined
within policy cs15 of the core strategy
which expects all development and
existing settlements to protect and
enhance the character of the settlement
with regards the above mentioned we are
firmly of the opinion that Green Lane is
being developed to accommodate modern
day living and with this comes the
latest in contemporary architecture
we're proposing a design that is simple
in its form but is using modern
materials modern fenestration and gives
more than passing to the local thank
you right any questions please can the
vs yes this is a replacement dwelling
correct um are
those did the car
before after reverse back or are those
parking spaces to turn on the picture
that we have
there um our idea is that yes you will
pull in nose first and you will park and
then you'll have the ability to then
pull backwards towards the house and
then uh drive out onto the road nose
first we wouldn't be reversing out onto
the main
road we've we've got two um but we've
got scope to amend those spes to
suit K
ctle okay yeah mentioned SS 20 quite a
bit um
obviously the uh a replacement dwelling
should not be significantly larger than
the existing dwelling obviously this one
is so it's touched on in the report just
like to hear your thoughts on that
please um yeah um I think I
wholeheartedly agree it's uh it's it's
it is a larger um replacement than than
what is there present um he's not going
sorry got by way okay okay um but um
we've just taken into account the
locality what we see there in terms of
other replacement dwellings there and
we've come up with a a plan and a
reduced scheme actually we were slightly
bigger than that before um to match in
on time with with what we see there okay
thank you any other
questions no you're free to go thank you
right ccel the
Fielding come on down you got five
minutes councelors again thank you for
putting out with me um I think if you
look at the update sheet with regards to
this you will see the
CPR has um made objections that are very
relevant to
um the
parish uh have said
um I'm objecting up to this
proposal um on the ground of the size
and the width it must have been a
shoehorn that's getting that in there
and a narrow plot that is was a sight of
a former pre prefab Bungalow as youve
heard to replace this property but a
four bedroomroom house is too large
oxville has its fair share of four or
five bedroom properties and under the
parish plan the PC is looking for
smaller properties to allow for people
to downsize the committee has turned
down developments on on the grounds of
too many large houses in our in the
district what could Road in the village
has four to five large four to five
bedroom houses also Green Lane there
which is further up from this site there
are similar amount of large
properties the local Villages need two
to three bedrooms both in tyo which is
neighboring Village uh to allow for
young families to buy and to allow
others to Dan size villages in the
district will become dormitories for the
better off who can afford to send their
children to fee paying schools and tyo
Village School that is requires young
families is short of
pupils it's if the committee want to
approve this development I must ask that
a it is delayed until a site visit can
be
arranged as you will note
from
as10 small scale schemes for
houses again which is what we have
discussed earlier on in parishes buil up
area
boundaries also within physical confines
in accordance with C5 and 16 with
developments the conversion of
residential it doesn't fall in my view
within most of what we're talking about
here we do need to replace the Bungalow
it is not an attractive property but we
do need to have common sense with
regards to the size of the property and
also taking into account the needs of
the
parish um requirements under CS 20 which
is proposals will preserve an enhance a
character to the locality I don't think
you can class that as enhancing the
locality the CPR agrees the proposal for
a new house should help achieve
sustainable mixed communities that with
all the other large houses in the
village is definitely not helping to
sustain a mixed community is the term in
the application other material planning
considerations will be taken into
account particularly the impact on the
highway
safety Green Lane is not in Winter
salted it's a fairly dangerous road very
large agricultural Vehicles go along
there the main road through the village
past the P has pinch points and that is
dangerous but it is salted and the buses
do go along it
so there are a number of reasons why in
my view that this should be turned down
and a view taken to provide a smaller
property than you can the fiing any
questions can
M John um I may miss something earlier
was any consultation with the Parish
Council on from the developer on this do
you know I'm not aware that there was
any okay
you mentioned your presentation caner
fing you wouldn't mind a site visit can
you clarify the reasons for request that
please you mentioned the site visit um
can you clarify the reasons basically to
show you how narrow the site is how
small it is um
and it really as you can see from the
cars in the drive it is a a very narrow
site okay there the other site that I
haven't referred to is that the field
behind this property the Le we've had
problems with springs that have come up
and caused flooding right the way
through the village there is a
danger um you can't really see where the
leaves is but the pubs and the other
houses along the Main Street have all
been affected by the springs that after
the snow we had two years ago of course
lot of problems and I think there could
be a further problem here
K well we got that picture of it looks
to me as though they're all big houses
along a rural
road that a question yes
yeah right C the Fielding you're free to
go move on to points of clarification
for the officers please any
clarification the
kettle um the Google Earth photograph
that You' got there Joe um is some years
old I think because there's been quite a
lot of
development um behind this property is
that correct or or Planning Commission
has been approved for development behind
the
property uh no C is not cor there has
been planning permission approved up
here for further dwellings um I do
photos of and dwellings if you wish to
see them um respectively at the minute
Green Lane is just representative of
this
area is is there not uh a Development
coming off the road to the right hand
side of the of the picture sort of
coming in where your thing is about
now I think the answer to that question
chairman is we're not sure we're happy
to check would you like to adjourn the
meeting while we do the
checking I the reason for my question
was um because if those developments do
include a number of two two or three
bedroom houses then that does challenge
the concern about this being a four
bedroom house that was the reason I'm
raising it um because I think this um
village has looking at
it um will have delivered 36 new
homes um in the latest um fiveyear
housing land Supply calculation I just
wondered you know does that mean there
are um smaller houses that have been
built in the
area I'll be honest uh with that it's a
simple case that this is a proposal for
one dwelling and in accordance with our
core strategy and the mppf you have to
basically consider one dwelling on its
own and on its own
merits
okay you that we we all clear we all
clarified are we that c the Mills thanks
um Joe could you put the
um yeah that's it um you you've got
Ferndale there and you've got the
Bungalow next to it
um I mean Ferndale is a big big old
property
um is that is that to scale up
there
the only answer is yes canc you can see
there's a scale bar within there so yeah
if it's a scale fine
fine right are we okay right should we
go to the debate then C Mills thanks Mr
chairman yeah um as you know I I I
always visit the site I have to say
spent three hours looking at this
yesterday at s worn out a lot at the end
anyway um looking good on it I'm looking
good on it yes I'm not
uh
yes I think we shouldn't set Ferndale as
a president I mean his large house there
large houses all the way along that that
that road there and I think we try to
out do each other large Ness there such
a word
um I I can't see why we can't you place
like for like okay I know this is a very
very bad preab building it's awful at
the moment but um and it would
dwarf um The Bungalow next to it and it'
be sandwiched
um I there is uh um I feel there's a
need for bungalows there's always need
for bungalows um why can't we have
another Bungalow there but but a decent
one so um I'm sorry Joe I gu
is off's recommendation on this Mr
chairman I don't like it and you'll be
coming up with some fing reasons I I
certainly
will can the
bars well um some years
ago we had a what was called an
environmental
disaster application just like this in
the village right next to the golf
course and all the people in the golf
course think it looks lovely
now I appreciate it's
environmental I can't see a reason for
refusal in the respect that all those
houses are lar asage it isn't the same
as the others and it isn't how I would
want to live but all I'm saying is we've
had two in our village now one right by
the golf course which everybody looks at
and they come to like it so as far as
I'm concerned although it may Su where
it is I can't see a pled reason for
refusal right can cattle I think I'm I'm
I'm I don't know about his house by the
golf course I mean I do have a concern
when you get villages uh and thinking
particular of admington which had a
number of very small properties in a row
somewhat similar to this Lane um and
there now got a number of significantly
larger houses um the reason I was asking
about development behind I think there
probably is I mean there are 36 new
properties already in Ox Hill this is
not a new property this is replacement
property so we're not talking about
housing Number issue
here I I think my only reason if I was
to if the word be grounds would be on
design I can't see any other reason to
refuse it um and I think that's a very
weak recent to refusal so um I think
probably I'm coming from the same him
sheet as Council BS on this one it's not
it's not ideal um it is very I think it
is going to be a challenging one to
start off with and I think people in The
Bungalow in the middle will will feel
somewhat sort of um between um a rock
and a hard place as you might say but I
don't think that's reasonable
refusal we had several analogies Golf
Course rocking the hard place um
can so are you proposing can the bars to
are you proposing to yes I'm quite happy
to propose it
yes did you say you going to
second okay and before we go that so
anybody else want to comment on this
application okay
fling I think to use an old phrase and
you know we're going to use these sort
of things all progress isn't forward but
the whole point about this this is the
modern way that houses seem to be going
and live in 1940s Bungalows or we allow
sort of communities to move forward and
obviously by the next door but one house
that's already started to move in that
direction too many programs unlike Grand
designs on TV really for these sort of
things that keep cropping up and and to
be honest this is the modern way that
people want to live and in reality
without a real reason or a real planning
reason to refuse it um we have to allow
prog to move forward and uh from that
reason I see no reason why I could
object to it so are you saying that
you're support councel Bond's proposal
for
approval so we've got a a proposal we've
got a
second I just ask condition as to
whether in view of our climate change
position whether we have sufficient
provision in there to ensure that this
is uh takes maximum use of renewable
energy uh possibly with it is a modern
building let us see the very latest
features in terms of renewable energy um
would be would I think be a very strong
message to other developers that this is
the way we're going to go and I think
this is a classic case to do it and I
see Council junor as long going to
support me on that one which is a pleas
change the one I've got profit on
electric and water yeah okay just
chairman inevitably new house will be of
a better Energy Efficiency standard than
the previous house and I would hope that
um the officers would use every effort
to make sure that we a achieve the
highest that's
permissible anything else did you
indicate yeah thanks for yeah I I think
it's essential that people go and look
at these prop uh applications I mean if
they look at this one um there is a they
are huge on there and everybody's trying
to outd do each other but you know you
trying to fit a quart into a pipe pot
here that have gone over you know went
over size of this uh Bungalow so my
reason for U refusion on this will be
can we go Bulan size for just for for
one so you are Mr
chair so D agre if we are minded to
agree this U the
recommendation what reasonable condition
can we put on for energy usage
Etc it's it's reuse of of the facilities
at the
sun and the water and everything because
that's what this s house is there
for it won't have Windows that open and
let everything through because that
isn't the way they're built yeah we're
going from d for reminded to agre thank
you chairman
um policy CS2 is your controlling policy
in the core
strategy um and policy CS2 is
encouraging but it gives us very little
uh chance to
require uh and as a result my
recommendation to you is not to impose a
condition requiring anything
but certainly to use notes on the
application form encouraging the
applicant to uh carry out the
development in the most sustainable way
possible uh my my advice to you will
change over time as policies come on
stream but as things stand at the moment
that is
uh the full strength uh that we have to
require CS2 which is an encouraging
policy and uh partel of the building
regulation does that allow us more of
leeway I'm
sure I'm sure a building control officer
could help you but I'm afraid it's not
planning um it's controlled through the
building
r c CLE um Dale um section two of
CS2 construction
materials um there exists materials um
that we read about a lot whereby um can
actually be used for generating
electricity in their own right um and
therefore there is I would have thought
under CS2 the opportunity to be rather
more robust than we have in the past
particularly given the policy that we
adopted last time around I I think
Council jit is D more up speed on these
things um but everything we do needs to
I believe push not just towards energy
retention but energy generation and I
believe S2 sub paragraph 2 the
construction materials could be used to
focus to what we should be looking at in
this in this
case if members wish to pursue that line
I'm sure we could contrive a condition
to that
effect can drive you mean come up with
an appropriate condition
then sloppy English apologies um compose
an appropriate condition for agreement
by the chairman happy I'm happy with
that thank
you right we've had a proposal seconded
by C Fleming sorry C Fleming to approve
the application subject to notes
conditions that we've just discussed and
some will be dedicated to agree
agreement with myself we go to the
vote all those in
favor against one ch
so that's six and one yeah PR quickly
committee resolve to Grant application
F thank
you right our next application is
19692 Holly
Cottage uh o h Lane yarning common War
demolition of existing kennel Cy
building and erection single story
dwelling resubmission of plan
application
forg
come on then carry on please
Peter far away when you're ready
plac thank you chair this application is
for the demolition of an ex existing
kennels and catery and the erection of a
single story dwelling it is an outline
application with all matters reserved
except for access the site is identified
here by a black dot below the site and
to the right you can see clabon the site
is within Yale common a small cluster of
dwellings outside of
clavam the site can be seen here
outlined in red one can see the foot
paaths which bound the site to the west
and
south on this location plan one can see
that the kennels is directly adjacent to
Holly Cottage and shares an entrance and
parking area the land to the South
within the red line is a lawn area
currently used for the
kennels this site plan shows the current
arrangement of the buildings on
site this plan shows the proposed
dwellings bear in mind that as all
matters are reserved except for access
this is indicative you can see that a
parking area would be created and the
access would be shared with the existing
dwelling here is an illustrative drawing
comparing the existing and proposed
principal
elevations and here's a photograph of
that same
elevation uh chairman the recommendation
is to refuse this application for the
reasons outlined in the report on page
125 of the committee pack thank you that
first Speaker canc
please didn't you want to come up
there sorry chairman I should know the
form
really far away you got three minutes
you know the thank you very much I
should do it in time um clav and PC have
considered this application and devoted
unanimous ly to give it our support the
reasons are listed on page 119 of the
officer's report and we're pleased to
see that the officer considers the
development to be acceptable in terms of
green Bel impact and further in respect
of the viability or unviability of the
business and its positive impact in
respect of the neighboring immunity from
reduced noise and traffic we are very
mindful of the positive comments on the
proposed uh proposal from local
residents and as um the report says 25
letters of support have been received
District Council support is here and
there have been no objections councilors
in respect of policy the council
believes it does comply with cs22 on
that could or should be developed part
on page 120 we believe that this
dilapidated building um should be
redeveloped and not due to planning
interpretation to be simply left a rot
as several of the buildings in clavan
currently are the officer considers that
our emerging neighborhood development
plan to be put to a referendum next
month is an important document and
Carries weight we would tend to
agree what we do not agree is the
interpretation of our housing policy H1
H2 and A3 I can claim some experience
here as I was one of the team that
drafted the policy the reason for
refusal is that the scheme does not
Accord with policy H1 which aims to
restrict and deter unsuitable
development outside the Village builtup
area the officer relies on this and
claims considerable weight the policy is
however not designed to be a catch all
to totally prohibit housing
outside the village built up area it is
tempered tempered by two following
policies H2 and H3 the officer considers
H1 and H2 to be in conflict and this we
believe is Inc an incorrect
interpretation whilst H2 deals with
affordable homes it does allow for
Market homes where there is an an unmet
need there is a need for small Bungalows
and houses that will release existing
family sized houses onto the market The
Proposal makes this meets this condition
as there are current there no AA sites
within the builtup area policy H2 is
also met in this
respect the key is the exception set out
in policy H3 on pages 121 and 122 The
Proposal meets all of the Five Points in
that it is compatible it is an
enhancement it doesn't conflict with
green belt policy and it does not lose
land of environmental value so our
interpretation is the plan meets so much
of the overall policy it out breaks
planning or it outranks policy H1 um
finally there is a point on E1 of our
policy which relates to business and it
covers that we would urge members to
vote in favor of the application this
should be
the can't because this should be that
council's rightly consider this to be a
sustainable development in a rural area
fully meets the cavant neighborhood
development plan in respect of Housing
and employment thank you
chair thank you Corton that was very
very six any questions
CS
1977 approval was given presumably this
has been kept as a Ken since
then um the applicant will be speaking
Council of bars but yes I believe it's
been a kennel certainly for the 30 years
I've been in the
village else thanks hi s good to see you
um can you confir this this is included
in the emerging neighborhood development
plan uh yes it is councelor the
emergency the emerging development plan
is due for referendum on the 24th of
October the policy that covers housing
H1 as as we would in a green belt era we
don't want individual houses built in
the green belt but the policy is
tempered and that's my point by policy
H2 and H3 which does allow building on
exceptional sites this being one of the
in that is it is an existing building um
it's not green belt it's not green land
although it's in Green Belt but that's
not an issue the the business we're
absolutely convinced is is kaput it's
been on the market I've seen the estate
agents reports and they're woeful as you
probably know the current trend is for
people to put their cats and dogs in
with a a dog minder rather than a kennel
and it's it's it's there are seven
businesses in cloudon that do this alone
and probably double that in Henley um so
completely convinced that there's no way
that this building can ever be used for
any employment use so it fills our
policy E3 of our emerging development
plan and it's it's is it being used at
the moment or it's I mean I I saw it I
saw it it didn't that it's been in use
for a long time um it is still in use
but I believe that well we've seen the
accounts that the income from it just it
doesn't it doesn't warrant um it doesn't
even employ one person um so it's it's a
dead business and we would rather see it
developed into a smart three-bedroom
Bungalow that we want rather than just
be left to rot for 10 years or whatever
not not for cats no not the cats and
Lista not feeline too
well oh
dear
sorry right
can't
um I didn't quite catch because I was de
as an Old Post are no longer in use is
that right no um sorry G no the Kels are
in use but very vially is there a a
nuisance element of noise Etc that's
affecting the
neighbors there is an element of noise I
walk past on my way to the Rugby Club
over Saturday and you do hear dogs
barking there there is traffic so that
will improve the situation I would
actually point out again in clavan there
is another kennel um on Li Green Road
there is a caty nearby we we've got
plenty of revision within the village
for looking after pets so we're not
going to miss this
business quite surprised counc NS didn't
say it' be a catastrophe if this was
moved but but sorry about that so
another it was another poor joke it was
yeah right come on get back to a serious
Point uh any other questions or is
cancel comments right right you're free
to go cancel thank thank you chair thank
you
counselors right um we've got the
applicant next which is ungranted
apologies for the K9 feline jokes
um it's been a long night but we are
taking your application seriously so
rest assured about that if you could
press the button you've got three
minutes um I have um two pictures
please thank you three minutes we've run
the kennels for eight years but the
buildings have subsidence and other
structural issues and need investment
which cannot be supported by profit
levels marketed the kennels with a
specialist Agency for almost a year with
no interest removal of the kennels will
not result in loss of employment and
there is no impact on the Green Belt
indeed it will improve the appearance of
the area with a house which will easily
integrate into the landscape the council
accepts all these things the only
possible way to make the business viable
would be to upgrade the existing
infrastructure significantly increase
the number of kennels and dogs and
employ a Workforce to meet new def
kennel regulations however this would
have an even greater aders on near
neighbors traffic levels and green belt
with these things in mind we believe
there are three reasons to grant our
application one yarningale is a
sustainable location the kennel lies
within a builtup run of houses clav and
Rugby Club is a couple of minutes away
and there are public foot paths um
direct to clavan providing easy access
to all the villages amenities our
children frequently walked and cycled to
the Village School and we often walk to
the Village along the foot paths we are
part of Travon local community and
support and enjoy many local activities
secondly there's already president the
officer's report interprets cor strategy
policy cs22 as not supporting
residential Redevelopment outside
defined Villages however this is at odds
with their approach on other SES such as
Henny Water Gardens on the Henley Road
and be Lane which you've looked at this
evening both of which lie outside any
built-up boundary the officer's report
for heny Water Garden specifically
states that provisions of cs22 support
residential development outside Village
boundaries this seems to us to be
sensible view as otherwise you would end
up with lots of derel and vacant sites
across warshire we don't understand why
a different interpretation has been
applied to us when the policy has not
changed thirdly and my other picture
please the officer's report does not set
out the other material considerations to
support our application these are the
removal of penals from a residential
area bringing about reduction in traffic
from the current 20 or so daily car
movements providing a new home for us in
line with Clan's housing survey that
includes a 23% reduction in floor space
making good use of an unviable
Brownfield site to provide an energy
efficient home including solar panels
and batteries ground Source heating
electric charging point to continue to
charge our L and leaf and require less
energy usage than now in summary
yarningale is a sustainable location is
president of similar applications being
granted and our application will bring a
positive impact as recognized by our
Parish Council Ward counselor and over
25 local people including close
neighbors we've had no objections thank
you very much thank you very much any
questions for the
applicant
no we just
um Council Lorton said the the business
was gradually um running
down um how many Al just about the the
movements you said about 20 movements
today for a for a business that's
slightly running down and okay yeah um
and that those are the movements as now
we have a peak time during the the
summer holidays so between um June June
and September that when with the school
holidays uh that we are at at we have
our peak time then it will be you know
completely dead over over the winter
months and then we have a bit of a Peak
at the Christmas period as well so the
movements are very concentrated in the
peak times yeah okay ask thanks
clarify um do we have a plan of this
Bungalow proposed
bungalow
and do actual
view okay yeah okay thank
you right oh caner flaming and Fielding
just wondering whe because it matched of
his shirt that he wanted that plan um
with regards to the foot path that you
were showing I probably I didn't
properly hear what is that the roots you
walk the dogs around or is what is the
significant of the foot path um the foot
paths are about our sustainability and
our closeness to
claven that to point out that we are
that we we are part of claven we're not
very far
away so the dogs are exercised uh in in
the
garden
J the um the the the applicant you have
mentioned uh various um things that
you're willing to consider
including um
energy various Energy Systems and
efficiency Etc just um it's not really
the time to ask for officers but um no
I'll I'll leave that one you but that
you have you have actually positively um
mentioned yeah if you could put my other
slide up of the of the kennels if you
see on the top of the kennels there
those there are about 25 solar panels
that we had installed a couple of years
ago and from those panels we uh we
charge our electric car um we um and we
would look in the new uh new build to
have battery storage so that we could uh
utilize the power even better than we do
now we we are very eco-friendly okay
thank
you you're free to go thank
you canor
Richards could you turn turn that other
one off while you there please can you
turn the other microphone off or or use
that one
whichever and could you move that chair
as well
please five minutes far away thank you
um members I'm here to in support of
this application um you'll see in the
update sheet my key reasons for that
support I'm going to now try and outline
those a little bit further for you um
typically applications in the green belt
national and local policies tend to erir
on the side of caution with development
being generally considered
inappropriate however as set out by our
case officer the proposed development
does in fact fit with green belt policy
and is considered acceptable in respect
to uh core strategy policy cs10 the case
officer goes on to The Proposal is
supported by core strategy policy CS5
and cs9 specifically it is stated that
in the report there is considered that
the proposed scale and layout would
successfully integrate in into its
surroundings without having an
unacceptable negative impact on the
appearance of the surrounding
environment the proposed development is
also supported by policy cs22 which
states that an existing employment site
should not be redeveloped or converted
to non-employment uses unless it is no
longer viable or appropriate for bus use
the applicant has shown by provision of
rigorous assessment that the chals are
no longer viable or sustainable that
position has been accepted and supported
by the case officer in this in the
report and it is therefore considered to
be supported by policy
cs22 so this application therefore seems
to hinge appears to hinge on the balance
between these supporting policies but
also policy cs15 and as10 it's important
to note that policy cs22 does not
require proposals involving the
Redevelopment of employment sites to
strictly comply with the Strategic aims
of policy cs15 and as10 and indeed the
core strategy guidance on both policies
advises that development affecting
employment sites must be assessed
against
cs22 so as such um as it has been
demonstrated that employment site is no
longer viable or sustainable and there
is little future Prospect of employment
continuing on the site the general
principle of the Redevelopment can and
should be supported this position is
also supported by national policy
through the updated MP
the balance therefore appears to fall in
favor of the development it's also worth
noting that there are further benefits
to the development it is supported by
the clar and Parish Council who have
stated earlier today um a clear need for
three-bedroom dwellings a position also
supported by the claven NDP specifically
policies H2 and H3 and H1 which covers
employ sorry E1 which covers employment
um this development would obviously meet
the needs um of of clav Council the
development also fits where the emerging
climate change agenda agenda by
providing an En energy efficient home
incorporating solar panels and a ground
Source heat pump significantly reducing
the energy usage and carbon footprint of
the existing
building clearly it's up for you as
decision makers to give the appropriate
balance to the policies of our core
strategy in my opinion the benefits of
The Proposal alongside the supporting
policies of CS5 cs9 cs10 and cs22 of our
core strategy put signicant
put sufficient and significant weight in
favor of this application and it should
therefore be supported also bear in mind
we have 25 letters of support from local
residents with no objections from any
sary
consules and we'll leave it with you to
make a decision thank you councelor
Richards any questions for the ward
member cancor
BS you may not be able to say but this
Bungalow how much bigger is it we have
at the Pres um so obviously I can't do
the sizes but you will have seen if you
look at this that image on that right
hand side versus that image there on the
right hand side to me that looks like a
smaller footprint your case officer will
be able to clarify that for sure but I'm
pretty sure that it is a smaller
footprint than the existing I'm just
thinking whether it's appropriate if you
see what I mean did you say smaller
footprint or po
print never
sorry about that I just thought we've
gone on for such long
while
any well we've listen to you or not can
Kett so I think we're GNA no we won't go
there sorry K Mills did you indicate no
any no right right I think you're free
to go thanks very
much all right move on to points of
clarification and hopefully we've teased
most of them out already cancel the bars
and cancel
I just checking the size B and mass
compared with what there
that's yeah the um proposed Bungalow
would have a smaller footprint um than
the existing kennels and roughly similar
height
there this is outline um but there there
was clear indication that um The
Proposal would provide an energy
efficient home Etc solar panel panels
Etc um given what the officers were
saying about the um the course strategy
at the moment we can only encourage we
can't uh condition um is there any
advice that if this is um passed and if
it comes to detailed planning
application that we can uh what can we
do other than just encourage under the
current uh plan planning rules
we want to go out but we're going to get
the right decision don't we so there's
no point and bearing in mind it's nearly
5 to 10 I think seconds of waiting for
more explanation we'll we'll get the
right
answer um I think it would be reasonable
to ask them well I think it would be
reasonable to condition that the
existing solar panels are carried over
onto a new dwelling I don't think it
would be reasonable to um condition that
extra renewable sources are provided or
bit they might have been indicated in
their submission could also note the
commitment made by the applicant tonight
and also was mentioned um I assume that
was again from information provided by
the applicant to the ward member Who
quotes um by providing an energy
efficient incorporating so the panels
undergr Source heat pump Etc um there is
some commitment both being and for the
applicant so we we know that and
encourage that as much as
possible is that
reason right cancel the field in then
cancel the kettle then can
um there points of clarification by way
we're not in the debate so can we stick
to that this is a Brownfield site isn't
it and as such it can be
developed it is a Brownfield site um and
it could be developed if it was in
accordance with the core
strategy for residential
use but it appears that it's it's within
their neighborhood plan that it is a
Brownfield site and they should be able
to be developed um I think our
interpretation of the neighborhood plan
differs slightly from um councilor
Lorton if you read the wording of policy
H1 um the overall sort of housing policy
it is tempered by policy H2 but it
doesn't mention being tempered by policy
H3 which refers to Brownfield land um
and also the development of this type is
not supported by as10 and cs15 so in
that respect there is a conflict with
the core strategy which hasn't been
overcome
so just before s just before you press
the button am I right in remembering
that this neighborhood development plan
isn't yet made yes it's at referendum
stage so we're back where we've been
previously tonight members the amount of
weight you can give to this neighborhood
plan is limited because the plan isn't
made once the plan is made it will be
the most up toate representation of your
development plan and it will have
different
weight
I'm interested when the image of the
property the garage is sort of being
halfway away from the property is there
a reason why it was designed that way
or or was it in your interpretation that
it should be there this image here this
image here are you referring to this
image on the SP now are you referring to
the one that you show the house the two
houses side by side this one nice green
one
the garage which you refer
to oh the parking down the bottom um
well I mean it's their choice where
they'd like to put it I don't envis a
problem with
it unusual perhaps
but I think we're okay I think we're
okay you want to clarify Point yes point
of fact come on there I didn't hand got
my glasses on so I didn't realize it was
you for a minute so sorry about that
it's not not just anyone so um the point
of fact I want to raise now if you all
turn to page 121 of your report and look
at paragraph
two um paragraph two says CL NP was
examined by inspector and is dued to
proceed to referendum as such it can be
afforded significant weight significant
weight has been applied to it within
this report your case officer has just
advised you that it can't be given
significant weight it's one or the other
no that's a fair point get clarification
thank
you
ref chairman I apologize and Council
Richards is of course
correct are we yet to move to the debate
no it's on clarification at the
moment any other questions okay we'll
move on to the vate now then I think um
I remember councelor Barn saying about
an application in my Village dong years
ago uh when application receives the
support of all of the ward member the
parish and significant numbers of uh
residents um that uh some Merit
approving that application I think we're
exactly where we are here it
is um yes it doesn't comply with as10
but if we can condition the development
to have an equal or or lower footprint
than the existing things that um um the
new building it may not reuse the
existing solar panels because they might
not they might pass sell by date but if
we have a building that continues with
the energy generation of the current
building I see no um reason not to
support this application even it is
contrary to the office's
recommendation CC bars and CC field then
CC
yeah me and councelor K have agreed on
two things
tonight and
I've gone along with the officer's
recommendation all through the evening
but I do feel that the appropriate House
of the appropriate size here I could
approve I think we need probably more
conditions but I'm quitea to propose
approval
F in my way think it's a Brownfield site
it's therefore right for development uh
I go along with C said and also councel
bars and I would like to go against the
planning officers grant for refusal I
want like it granted can some else yeah
I think we all have won mine here um yes
having a dwelling here will reduce the
uh traffic flow down there long as they
fix that down drive down there bottom
the car out it yesterday um
yeah it is Improvement I I thought
reading this there is a I think there is
a a conflict on between the neighborhood
development plan but
um unfortunately Sarah I'll have to uh
going against his off officer's
recommendation this one I'll go for
Grant thank you okay to both while on
here um obviously we've we've been told
and finally clarified that the NDP cares
material weight and it's the most up
toate version um and
basically just I'm clarifying it s of
like supersedes the core strategy or is
it's
more no CH sorry we can't go quite that
far um doesn't yet have full weight most
yes it has significant weight not full
weight once it has full weight then
obviously it will then sued sued your
your core strategy y okay thank you
um I must admit I am agreeing with most
of the members here that I think we
should be approving this
application
um as long as we can come up with
material planning reasons to go against
officer's
recommendation
um we've had a proposal and a seconder
for the application but I don't think
we've teased out the the reasons for
well I think the ward member gave good
reasons in planning terms he can
reiterate them but as far as I'm
concerned it will be enhancing the area
the green belt but you did give two
reason for if you
could help
me
22 well you just said
so
yeah all
right it's all word
here I
think
22 that's number that's what
policy right I think the other I I think
it's sufficient for for you to say you
adopt the reasons given by the ward
member um you don't you don't need to
read I think it's sufficient for you to
say you the reasons given by the ward
member and you agree with them that's
that's fine yeah basically accepting
andp H3 and yeah we agree I would add
the par the parish counselor's comments
because I think he was equally helpful
in putting forward policy reasons both
from the
NDP Bri who we
got
we're gradu
no you're not going
home we just clarify this bearing in
mind we've had an application at the
start of the meeting where we have to
come back and altify alter and clarify
the reasons for application we need to
make sure we get the right application
we right policies so we're not
challenged Etc so even if we're here
till a bit longer
we will get these right and make sure
that the minutes are produced from this
meeting we've got the right reasons the
right policies rather than the ones that
we think we're interpreting
so
cs22 so I've been advised that policy
cs22 might
be slightly challengeable but if we're
happy to accept that the NDP
H3 reason holds weight and
cs10 um I think the offices will then be
able to come up on formulate some
reasons for approval going against
officers recommendation are you happy
about
that right condition and the conditions
will be agreed myself and the officers
chair sorry it's not for the officers to
formulate reasons for approval no they
are advising ways for
for if we reminded to approve we I sort
to advice from Dale so if there's any
fault there it's my fault um I've been
trying to go along with the flavor of
this debate I think we seem to be minded
to approve this and bearing in mind like
sayate re restate what we had at the
start I need to make sure that the
reasons for approval are
appropriate um and I don't want to go
through what we did ear at start of the
meeting so yeah I can see where you come
from Ross and that's more informative
it's it's appearing like that so I'll
take the blame for
that are a very position here where
everybody who looks at surrounds the
site Etc ET support the application I
know but I'd rather air on the side of
caution I'm just pointing that out that
it's very different to The Nap side
but air on the side of caution so
anybody else got any comments
d
a
second
yeah
contribute chair if I may apologize for
that um what Ross and I were discussing
was
uh the the issue of principle you the
report sets out a certain line of logic
and I think if I've understood what
members are saying correctly you're
saying that those two policies that you
you've written down
there NDP policy H3 and policy cs10 are
satisfied by this development and
because those policies are satisfied you
are satisfied that in principle this is
acceptable and if that's what I'm
hearing I can accept that I can support
that and we can go on from that
point yeah I think the committee is
saying that the principle of dment is
accepted here and so again if you want
anybody want to knowe that and clarify
that I think we'll go so Council BS is
proposed the approval after all the
reasons we've mentioned including NDP H3
and cs10 and we've agreed that we are
happy with the principle of development
on this uh plot uh can the field in has
seconded it so we will go to the vote
all those in favor of approving this
application in line with the conditions
and the reasons just stated please
vote anonimous
chair so Council resolves committee
resolves to Grant application
right thank you for that and thank you
for bearing with
me final application of the night is
TPO
8218 which is land at Walnut house 23
Hill and Acres down London Road shs
non you've been setting me up all night
there uh confirmation of tree
preservation order with modification
order covering one group of two
trees oh come
on we can do the K9 ponds lighter thank
you thank you chairman this final item
this evening relates to a tree
preservation order at a site in Shipton
and Stow local planning authorities can
make a tree preservation order in the
interest of amenity where it's
considered to be expedient to do so tree
preservation orders can relate to
individual trees groups of trees or
Woodlands the mppg guidance advises
there's a need to consider amenity in a
structured way having regard to the size
and form of trees fut potential to the
amenity of the area Rarity cultural
historic value and the contribution to
the landscape when viewed from the
public
realm to ensure consistency between
offices tree evaluation method for
preservation orders is a a proor that
officers follow to ensure
consistency when a tree pres
preservation order is made it comes into
effect and the trees are protected after
this time a consultation period takes
place the local planning Authority has
six months to consider any
representations received and make a
decision whether to confirm the order as
made to confirm the order with minor
modifications or to confirm or not to
confirm the tree preservation order
where a decision is not made the order
will lapse and the prot protection
afforded to the trees will fall
away unlike a planning application tree
preservation orders can receive
objection on any grounds not just
planning
matters where objections are received in
line with the council constition the
applications referred to committee for
members to
consider this slide shows the
approximate location of the site
identified by the black Dot site lies
within the built-up area boundary for
ships and on
Stow this slide shows the site and the
group with the two walnut trees in
question shown by the the broken green
line here public viewpoints include the
London Road to the west of the site and
Angela Meadow to the South there are a
number of other tree preservation orders
in the locality shown by the green
circles on this
plan to the right of this image is a
tree preservation Order Plan showing the
dash line and G1 which is a group of the
two warut trees sorry the two cedar
trees that have been subject to this
tree preservation
order this slide shows an aeral image of
the approximate location of the trees
you can see the London Road to the west
and Angeles Meadow to the South and the
dwellings associated for the trees
located here and
here this is a photograph taken from
Angeles Meadow to the South the two
trees in question can be seen in between
the buildings here and
here this photograph is taken from
Angela's Meadow looking North the two
trees you can see here and here on the
image this is taken between the
buildings from Angela Meadow looking
North and this image is taken from a
private parking area you can see the two
properties Acres down to the right and
warut Lodge to the left the trees lie
within the front Gardens of these two
properties this is a photograph from the
London Road looking Eastward you can see
the arrow there showing the trees in
question this Photograph was taken from
the London Road looking eastwards the
trees you can see in the center of the
image this Photograph was taken from the
private Drive sorry theate Drive warn
Lodge you can see on the right here with
the two out buildings it's a private
road that serves seven dwellings and the
two trees you can see in the center of
the
image this photograph is taken looking
at Acres down you see the two properties
warut lodges to the right and Acres down
is to the left with a private driveway
the out building and the other out
building associated with Walnut
Lodge this photograph is taken from
Acres Town looking towards the two
trees the trees measure approximately 22
meters in height and have a radial span
between 6 to 9 M you can see just
here these photographs are taken from
the other neighboring properties got
three far Hill looking back towards the
two trees and the paddock to the north
looking back towards the trees
here there is an update which is
contained within the update sheet the
officer recommendation is to confirm the
tree preservation order subject to a
minor change to the plan associated with
the order for the reason set out within
the committee report thank
you thank you Erin can we have our first
speaker please which is SAR Kahan and
apologies if I've um mispronounced your
surname
there don't get pra like that very often
so have to make the most of
that good evening counselors you've got
three minutes three minutes and we'll
give you a shout with 30 seconds pres in
my household at The Paddock and also my
neighbors at number three so I'd like to
take the four requirements for TPO first
the condition and suitability these
trees are most definitely now unsuitable
for the area the SDC height assessment
of the trees is 22 M therefore these
seeders will double in size to between
40 to 50 m with a trunk diameter of 2
and a half met at full maturity
regarding flood damage the debris during
a storm can be instant regardless of
regular maintenance if we're away during
a storm and unable to clear the drains
the storm water will run through the
front door of number three both trees
have longevity which guarantees future
residents the same problems on speaking
to locals about the TPO no one knows
which trees we're talking about and
they're not deemed to be a public
imunity by the locals regarding in
Rarity with nine seeders within a three
minute walk of f Hill and another two on
the town boundary these trees are not
rare nor are they rare in the
area point one of the tempo assessment
asks if the tree is deemed dangerous an
extensive survey done by the independent
tree consultant Mr Unwin finds them to
pose an unreasonable safety Threat by
contrast the first survey was done in
haste without proper
assessment these trees fulfill three of
the four criteria required to determine
a tree to be dangerous firstly they are
unsuit located and the Eastern tree
leans in the direction of the prevailing
wind towards number three were it to
fall it will hit the entire length of
this Bungalow secondly they've already
caused physical damage to visiting cars
unable to use the garage and two acres
down garage roof fortunately no one has
been injured yet but the elderly
Neighbors at number three fear being
struck by debris whilst in their Garden
or that the tree will fall and as you
can see from the pictures the debris can
be big live heavy Limbs and the branch
pictured here came down in June after
pruning and is a fair example of what I
have to drag off the drive regardless of
weather conditions there are no overhead
hazards but the fourth criteria regards
deterioration ofs stem or root system
even without deterioration the root
system is an issue and live limbs are
dropped it's a feature of the species as
confirmed in Mr unwin's report therefore
they can be considered dangerous trees
and are unsuit placed even if they were
conscientiously maintained they still
pose a danger to life and property we
urge the council to Bear liability and
safety in mind before making their
decision recommend three refuse to
confirm the order thank you for your
time thank you very much any K the
fing um the one nearest your that garage
there what are there any effects of
substance caused by the roots it's not
it making difficult to open the doors or
anything that you can actually ask Mr
Lang Mr Lang who's the owner of AC down
will speak next and he'll be able to
tell
there's nothing on your property then
that my my property is not affected no
not by The Roots except your dogs those
are my dogs yeah giving you sense of
size and
proportion any questions thank you very
much free to go and there's a dog over I
think the dog's 38 as
well I think it's a bit of a big Branch
for them to
carry very good thank you very much
very
good Mr
Lang good evening to keep you up too
late no sorry for keeping so
long so three
minutes far away when you're ready and
we'll give you a sh with 30 my wife and
I are the owners of AC down before we
purchased the coun the AC down the
council confirmed there were no
restrictions on any which allowed us to
plan to remove the dangerous Cedar to
the front post purchase the TPO was
served on this tree for the sole reason
of its public amenity value government
legislation 2014 defines public amenity
value by seven
criteria one orders should be used to
protect trees if their removal would
have a significant negative impact on
the local environment and its
enjoyment the only impact would be to
remove the huge health and safety risk
of pedestrians adj
buildings number two Council should
develop ways of assessing the amenity
value of trees the tempo method should
not be considered as according to the
tempo rules dangerous trees where the
danger cannot be remedied must not be
included in
Tempo if the hel well system is used
then the amenity value reduces to zero
as the tree is totally unsuitable for
its current setting and it's it
contributes nothing to the appreciation
of the
area number three visibility the trees
or at least part of them should be
visible from a public place a road or
foot path accessible to the public the
tree is at the end of a private cuac the
only sight line is a few meters along
the London Road where the very top of
the tree can be briefly glimps and
between the houses in Angeles
Meadow size and form the large size is
wholly unsuitable for its position being
next to buildings and above underground
services which are at risk of Dage
groups the form is mediocre at
best number five future potential as
nity no it's in a totally inappropriate
setting with no Public Access existing
building Works will continue to obscure
the trees
further number six Rarity cultural or
historic value it's not rare it's got no
cultural or historic value
whatever sevenly contribution to the
relationship within the landscape none
and in the wrong
setting therefore any attempt to justify
public commenity value as the reason for
placing a is unsustainable and tends to
fail the only sensible fair and
proportion outcome is not to confirm the
temporary TPO on eent tree and allow it
to lapse we will replace the theed with
a more appropriate tree 30 seconds even
if the tempo evaluation is used then the
following figures emerge part A scores Z
part B scores four part SC two score of
six points and one Z score Nows the
assessment as Temple rules direct any
TPO is
indefensible it's interesting to note
that Mr ONN wrote in his report the TPO
on G1 at F Hill was placed in a hurry
there was insufficient consideration
before the emergency TPO was installed
thank
you right thank you very much so spot on
one within
time K
some question before should I answer
that one no do that one first okay
sorry good evening um uh how long have
you lived in this property six months oh
right okay um um Sor I lost the track
there when was this TPO put
on if I could just explain we bought the
house on the 7th of March we moved in
sorry on the 7th of March and the first
thing we did was to uh get a tree
surgeon we got a tree surgeon to agree
to fill that tree because it was so
dangerous um the tree surgeon came he
was putting ropes up on the tree the TP
was served at that
point three weeks later sorry two weeks
later thank you right so you want to go
back to the point subsiders the previous
question I can't remember who asked it I
think it was subsidence was it asked
about the block Paving in front of the
garage there is considerable heave in
that block
Paving um it is causing trip hazards to
people who enter the house we've had
lots of workmen come in to do work on
the house and they are all complaining
they're tripping over all these Stones I
have actually managed to repair some of
them but there is large areas of he
there's four of them which if they
consider to rise will make the
garage you can't enter it no stop the
cars coming in and can I
F can we go back to the that picture the
fence between you and your neighbor does
it is it actually attached to the tree
no it's not the tree no Nails being put
into the tree no the tree is right on
the boundary between the two houses but
we understand from our solicitor it
belongs it your G that one is affecting
G C cancel sorry you were about to say
your
solic said something you w say your
something C building the solicitor
advises the tree to the right belongs to
our
neighbor the tree to the left belongs to
acres
down so we had no right to ask our
neighbor to fail his tree but we did ask
if we could prune tree so that the
didn't come over our garage and our
dway and of course we've now had to stop
that as
well was there actually any pruning
taking place looking at the dead Woods
we asked permission once the T had been
raised uh to take out dead wood from the
tree uh the tree surgeon then used up a
long of the money i' allocated for
filling the tree to actually take out
that dead wood in doing so um he had to
admit that he took one or two hours that
really wasn't many that were alive in
order to get to the dead wood which the
only way he could get to it okay so some
of the bottom of the tree has to move
but the rest of it is just as dangerous
as it ever was y can't some El thank you
um this movement of the block Paving has
that happened since you moved you was it
already it was already there okay thanks
I hasten to say it is getting worse c c
the photographs that we see there are
they before the uh Deadwood was removed
or afterwards that's afterwards that's
afterwards they were taken by your young
lady
there um about a week ago I think with
that
it'sing getting a bit deaf in my old AG
but is have you discussed with your
neighbor about taking that tree down and
is he in favor
our
neighbor there's a bit of a dichotomy
here it was our neighbor that found the
council when he saw the tree surgeon
coming to take tree down he founded the
council to have the TPO on it the tree
surgeon before he started work at 12:00
that day phoned the council to check
there was no TPO which is why he started
trying to start work within I don't know
an hour the TPL was served the point to
bear in mind is you will have noticed
there are
two expert reports saying the tree is
dangerous and should be removed one of
those
experts was commissioned by the neighbor
whil the TP be put on he's no objecting
to
it objecting to
it
yes so he said realizes he's made a big
mistake I think youve clarified that
just CL any further
questions Mr Lang you're free to go
thank you thank you and thank you for
answering the previous question it's
almost like the two running sketch isn't
it what I'm not going to do is ask the
future
one right thank you very much Council
bars it was a technical question really
can can
we have this order for short length of
time like five years
or what I'm saying is to assess them at
a later
date it's just a thought in my mind and
I thought I
would well I mean two years to five
years or whatever
but so once the order is made it's made
unless it's varied at a later date um so
when we we make a tree preservation
order it lasts for six months as Aion
tree preservation order where a
consultation period is carried out after
that time if it's not confirmed it will
lapse or if no decision is made it will
lapse after the six Monon period but
once it's made it then we'll hold and
the trees will be
protected the critical point is
councelor that the the decision can be
reviewed at a future date it's not
casting tablets of stone hasn't
saved question being asked I've had one
in that after two years they changed
their
mind do you understand because it
deteriorated and we can review any works
that come forward whilst the tree
preservation order protects the trees
yes if Works want to come forward we can
consider that um at that time and
whether or not we'd support the works
that are proposed I am correct man coun
CLE um this is a question for Erin um
your report on page
139 um you note the
obors the the objectives of Boral cons B
cultural cons States appears the trees
appear
healthy um although there was extensive
Deadwood which we've now been told been
removed that slightly conflicts with
what the owner of the AC said which was
there were two reports saying they were
dangerous uh we then go on
to the County Council surveyor who said
the trees were in fair condition using
tempus um and that there was Deadwood to
be removed and we then have a further
survey under pus which I don't know what
that stands for which says the tree was
reported to be
SED have you seen these reports that say
it's the two reports that say it's
dangerous so we do have the reports as
part of the file and they are summarized
in the officer report um just to confirm
the was on the 27th of March that's when
the tree preservation order was made and
it was carried out by an officer from
wer County Council on behalf of the
council he carried out a Tempo
assessment and the order was made on the
recommendations of the officer since
that time the consultation period has
run our own Tre officer has been out and
visited the site reviewed all the
representations and summarized it in the
officer report you've gotten the
committee pack tonight um and also had
regard to the two three reports that
were put forward um as part of the
consultation process um so they have
been reviewed um and and whilst they
have identified that there was Deadwood
that's now been removed I do have some
images of before the Deadwood was
removed this was prior to the Deadwood
being removed taken on the 27th of March
2019 and then you can see the
photographs below afterwards so the
Deadwood has been removed and that's
been assessed by the council's tree
officer um in terms of the reports have
been put forward um the initial
assessment was that the trees were in
fair condition they've been assessed
further since that initial assessment in
March um and there are two reports that
have been put
forward um the P this is put sonic wave
through the tree um where it's in good
condition it travels faster and they
they draw up a plan um and it has
reported that the tree is sound so the
bases of the trees are sound um but it
did make reference to the Dead now been
removed from the
crown yeah come on for a brief please
um
if a TPO is installed on these two
trees and there was further work
recommended to reduce the crown or or or
somehow we've heard stories about it
going up to 40 meters etc etc well that
can be controlled by Crown lifting and
various our bicultural works so
presumably they could be undertaken if
there was an application and that was
considered to be the best way to go
forward so if the tree pres preservation
order is confirmed Works can be carried
out to the trees but we'd have to assess
it's part of an application um so the
trees would still be protected but the
tree officer will review any works that
come forward as part of any sort of
further development to the trees so if
they were to grow up to another 10
meters or so that could be controlled by
Crown reduction or whatever the correct
ter might be yes we would review any
proposal that comes
forward although it is some 50 years
since I was involved in forestry when I
was maintaining 500 Acres of Woodland
and also looking after trees of this
nature it very much appears that those
trees are not too close together because
the leaves the branches are going off in
away from each
other I would think on the trees could
cause a problem um my gut feeling is
that they are mature they are
probably on the downside they're getting
too old and I think they should I don't
believe that the TPO should be put on we
were still on points of clarification
there we haven't gone to the debate
so can have any more points of
clarification because I think we should
go on the debate
now right
anybody want to start on this one
then
CC yeah um
gosh they been there obviously there
before the houses were built around them
um they were there first
um and I feel that
if tree officer um Ruth has been out to
examine them she feels they're
safe so the tree officer yes has been
out to visit the site has reviewed all
the representations that have come
forward and assessed them as part of the
officer report that's been put forward
this
evening um Ruth is very very experienced
I I will go with with a recommendation
here confirm the order so um yes I'll go
with the officer's recommendation on
this counc D
and the office of recommendation is
number two which allows does allow some
modification if if um felt appropriate I
believe yes that's correct the
modification is just a minor change to
the the the broken line and the group on
the plan so it's only a minor
modification that's proposed as part of
the opposite
recommendation C cut
um there are similar situations in my
ward where um TPA have been put on PRI
of development on the concern was
established in fact in one case by the
planning inspector um that one needs to
avoid the risk of future inhabitants
claiming the trees need to be removed
because of their lack of the damage to
the occupants imunity and I think we're
in exact same situation here
although about 30 years later down the
line to that which the inspector was
referring
um they are significant trees and I can
see badly maintained they would be of
concern I'm minded given the fact that
our tree officer who is experienced has
reviewed these trees has reviewed all
reports um
that amendments can be made to TP
at a later stage to improve the safety
of any particular tree um but it really
worries me when you get trees in an
urban setting and we've seen this in
Sheffield we've seen lots of other
places let's get rid of all the trees I
think that is a detrimental step and I'd
therefore be with the office's
recommendation
do I'm afraid I'm going on the opposite
tax I think those trees are getting to
be by
they are already losing branches they're
too close together and I can
see um that they could affect each other
each other and and the properties
particularly that garage which I gather
is already being affected by the roots
and as such I would um go along with the
applicants requests that they are
removed just for clarification can I
confirm that Council Fielding is Tech up
to speed and has kept his qualifications
as a forest up up to the current St
status my my qualifications are way too
slow now but looking at them and knowing
about
well I think
k k the field in your entitled to your
opinion and U yes you can give us
indication of your experience in the
past so you are entitled to your opinion
and to votes so I've got no shoe for G
that so um right any other people want
to talk on this one can
bars I mean I've got a whole village
full of TP trees which are sort of kept
an eye on I suppose you could say in my
respect and I know a bit about trees
they were planted in about
1882 uh they've got some time to go yet
in my personal opinion there look to me
like a a breed of tree that was brought
over by gwr in the respect of from
Canada um
and whatever Tre branches fall off it it
prunes itself naturally which is a
problem but as far as I'm concerned the
trees in my Village next to th cottages
and wherever I looked after problem is a
split then they come out look at it if
it's got to come down there isn't a
problem so it's an ongoing thing which I
think needs to be Illustrated to the
people that you know we won't just leave
them there for 100 years we will monitor
them so I'm happy to propose the
continuation of
the
T so have we got a proposal on the
second for this
can you propose counc C I'm happy to
propose the office
recommendation
okay so going to vote that we go with
the officer's
recommendation
to confirm the order with
modifications as in part two on page 141
is that one yes so to confirm the order
with
to the plan attached to the tree
preservation order just to relocate the
dash line for
clarity thank you should grle vote on
this one then all those in
favor six chairman
against one chairman two two
chairman committee resolves to confirm
the audit with modification of the TPO
plan thank you
we
have urgent
business close the me
him